e
all right if we all stand up for the
Pledge of Allegiance and representative
pleaseed Al to the flag of the United
States of America and to the Republic
for which it stands one nation under God
indivisible with liberty and justice for
all
good morning every everyone today we're
going to
um exec uh we're going to open the
executive session on four bills uh HB 69
HB
353 hb1 128 and HB
238 we have the amendment completed for
HB
225 but in order to afford everyone at
opportunity to read it and consider it
we're going to push the exec session on
that uh off for another
week couple of notes um from this m
morning's meeting with the speaker
before we get
started
um first of all it's the use of
computers and uh and cell phones during
committee uh and from the three or the
two committee meetings we've had I think
we're doing pretty well with that
biggest thing is to re that we need to
treat people giving testimony with
respect and dignity and so therefore
don't let it be a distraction but I
understand that certain things happen
and people take notes and do research I
got all that uh so please just continue
to do what you're doing and and not make
it a
distraction
um the other thing from this morning is
on parking and so if you have an
assigned parking spot like whether it's
it's down in the parking lot or if it's
along the the road you'll know that you
have it along the road if you don't know
you have it then you don't and so a bag
a bag over a a uh a meter is not your
spot unless you've been assigned that
spot it's for people that are whether
they're disabled or or whatever reason
that they've got um access closer um
they are going to start enforcing that
um which means a warning to the
committee and then a toe and so just
fair warning that you know that is sort
of a policy and truth be told I didn't
know that when I was a first year
freshman and I didn't get told but I
felt bad because I actually used one of
those and then I stopped using it so
just a fair
warning all right off to the business of
the
day uh the first it business is HB 238
an act prohibiting collective bargaining
agreements from requiring employees to
join or contribute to a labor union do I
motion and representative Granger I move
OTP you have a a motion to OTP correct
okay do I have a second second Mr
and would you have any comments to your
motion I think that everybody knows how
they're going to vote on this and I'm
sure we're anxious we got a busy day
ahead of us um so so I'll just leave it
at that okay thank you so much are there
comments represent Mr chair I have a
prepared statement I'd like to read if
that's possible I'll keep it brief As
You
Wish ladies and gentlemen of this
committee Comm let me start by
acknowledging the fire in the bellies of
those who spoke last session passion has
filled this chamber and we must respect
that but now is the time to stoke that
fire with some truth about the engine of
our New Hampshire economy our small
businesses we've heard the tales of
Union woes and benefits of the sanctity
of collective bargaining for the likes
of teachers electricians and
firefighters but what about the silent
majority the small to mediumsized
Enterprises those with fewer than 200
Souls the truckers the local innovators
the backbone of our state's economy
these are not the UPS Giants or the
municipal unions or the Detroit Auto
factories these are the businesses where
every employee knows the owner's name
and where the coffee is brewed by the
boss's hand let's be clear the Allure of
Union stability is undeniable who
wouldn't want the security or a golden
parachute for retirement but let's not
be fooled by the glitter of that gold
The Narrative that you if you don't grab
that pot the owner's will is not just
misleading it's an insult to the
hardworking entrepreneurs of New
Hampshire these owners have not only
Built these businesses from the ground
up but they have nurtured their teams
turning them into families and then
those into communities so why is it then
that these small business owners have
been conspicuously absent from this
discourse it's almost if we have decided
to ignore the very people who breathe
life into our local economies they have
been ignored and frankly as a business
owner I find it highly offensive I stand
here to remind my colleagues that
capitalism isn't the villain in this
story it's what provides the job jobs
and promotes Innovation it's what drives
our economy forward while unions have
their place I can assure you that New
Hampshire's small businesses are fully
capable of managing their own
employees respectfully it asks the
Committees to remember this without
these small business owners there are no
jobs let's not let the narrative be
hijacked by one side and let's Champion
those who have fought tooth and nail to
make sure New Hampshire is an economic
Powerhouse we can all be proud of I
yield back to my time thank you Mr
chair thank you sir are there any other
chairman we are here for one
purpose not to debate whether or not the
labor
movement uh should have minority
bargaining whether or not we should be
this should be a place for grievances we
here for one
purpose there is one car out in the n in
the Taft heartley law which is
14b and 14b gives States the right this
has nothing to do with the Union
environment it gives the states the
right to carve out that provision in the
collective bargaining agreements which
gives the employer and employee who have
negotiated uh terms and conditions of
their
employment it provides the opportunity
to carve that out now out of the
collective marking agreement now think
about that think about that from some of
the comments that have been made in this
committee we are a major contributor
labor movement is a major contributor to
the economy in New Hampshire and what
you're doing here is that you are
injecting into those relationships that
have been built for many many years
injecting into that into that
process you're taking away the right
that these people have to have shared
cost and shared responsibility because
those people who are under the umbrella
of the labor movement as part of the
law those people H are going to have the
opportunity to get all of those benefits
to take advantage of everything that the
labor movement has to offer and not pay
a single dime for that not a single dime
and that's what's that this is not not
about the overall labor move this is
about one
provision and the law is so specific
that many people don't know this but
they in the union Workforce if members
of that Union are unhappy with this
agency
fee what they can do is they can file if
30% of them want that out of their
contract they can file for an election
for that particular provision only
provision in law
the only provision of the Taft hot lead
allows people to do that to take that
provision out of that Collective bying
Agreement so Mr chairman let's let's
stipulate that people are not being
forced into
Unions that's the law they are not under
a condition of employment required to be
part of a union That's the Law they
can't be fired for not being part of the
Union that's the
laww and we have heard that all of these
arguments which actually misrepresent
the law so nobody in this United States
of America is being fired because they
don't want to be part of the union and
the only thing they can be required to
do right now is to pay that agency fee
if in fact the union negotiates it and
the agency fee is not the
dues it is only a slice of what it takes
to to negotiate the Collective buing
Agreement and manage the Collective
buing Agreement it's nothing beyond that
so it's not the dues that the other
members are paying and let me say one
final thing because I know a lot of
people have something to say right now
you could have somebody join the
Carpenters and you have the ref from the
Carpenters who talk about this join it
join the union enroll in the
Apprenticeship Training Program which by
the way we pay millions of dollars to to
build buildings and and and they could
basically leave the union and still be
part of the Apprenticeship Training
Program and we would be on the hook we
the labor movement would be on the hook
for the cost of that employee for their
whole career tell me how that's fair
tell me how that's fair people should
have to if they're getting the benefits
and that's our responsibility and we've
heard well you can get out we can do it
that's not before you what's before you
is tap hotly 14b and whether or not
people share in the responsibility and
whether or not as a public policy we
think people should take should be
responsible and should and the fair and
Equitable thing to do is to require
people if we negotiate that provision to
pay a portion to support the benefits
that they get the activities for the
benefits to get thank you Mr chairman
thank you representative uh if give me
pause
e
yeah so just to uh bring everyone up to
speed so uh representative fingon was in
a car accident this morning and we're
waiting to
determine how he's doing I don't know uh
just all I know is that he was in a car
accident so representative Maguire was
going to sit in for him and vote but
according to house rules we have to
provide 24 hours notice and so she will
not be able to vote and so we just want
to make sure that we're straight up with
everything and uh that's why she stepped
out and we can proceed is there any
other comments representative K thank
you Mr chair um we were all here last
week when we heard from primarily
members of the unions and you know they
emphatically told us that they thought
they were getting their money's worth
and probably more by being in the union
they made a big difference in what they
were able to accomplish in their lives
and for their
families and and while I I I respect the
comments of uh my colleague down the end
of the table that you know businesses or
are certain businesses are certainly the
backbone of our country so are our
workers and we haven't heard from the B
from the small businesses what we who we
heard from where the
workers and uh and you have you know
maybe you have a business where the
owner's making the coffee and but
sometimes there's a little can there
where you throw in a 50 cents when you
when you have a cup of coffee and I'm
just saying don't be that guy that come
in and has a cup of coffee and a donut
and walks past the can chip in something
you know because you're helping you're
you're doing something Beyond yourself
but you're making sure that cup of
coffee will be there next week when you
come in so I'm support I'm I'm voting
against this bill and I'm I wish we
wouldn't keep on seeing this but uh uh
it's it's really not the right thing for
New Hampshire I don't know that there
are I don't know that there are
companies unan anonymous anonymous
companies waiting to come in but I don't
think they're of workers waiting the
comments will only pass this bill so I'm
again it thank you thank you are there
any comments representative brard thank
you Mr
chair I I strongly oppose Right to Work
legislation in New Hampshire because it
undermines the rights of workers and
threatens and the economic well-being of
our
state right to work laws weaken unions
by allowing individuals to benefit from
collective bargaining without
contributing
their fair
share this leads to lower wages reduced
benefits and diminished workplace
safety not just for union members but
for all workers in right to work
states studies show workers in these
states earn 3 to 4% Less on average and
their communities suffer economically as
a
result New Hampshire has long prided
itself on local control
and a strong middle class this
legislation is driven by outof state
special
interests and does not reflect the
values of the Granite
State it risks creating division in
workplaces and weakening the collective
power of employees to negotiate Fair pay
and safe working conditions I urge this
committee to reject this harmful
legislation and protect the rights of
workers to organiz
and advocate for themselves together we
can continue to build an economy that
works for everyone thank you Mr chair
thank you sir any other comments any
other
representative thank you Mr chair um
just kind of piggyback on everybody
starting with representative L Bri I
mean uh it's nice that I am able
to go to small businesses because
that'll be my first choice if I'm going
to go spend some money it's going to be
to a small business in my area in my
town before I go to any any bigger you
know I'll rather go to a small lumber
yard to buy my material than a Home
Depot let's put it that way you know
stuff like that so I agree with you 100%
I'm all for small business and I and I
will spend my money there whenever I can
um to piggyback on representative uh
McKenzie I'm not a representative of the
Carpenters Union I'm a member of the
Carpenters Union just so that you know
there's no uh conflict of interest or
anything like that but I wanted to talk
about what he ended with was the uh the
apprenticeship the opportunity for young
people or even older people i' I've
dealt with and worked with a bunch of
people that have been through college
realized that what they did wasn't
making them any money wasn't what they
thought it was and have gone into the
apprenticeship in their mid-30s and
sometimes even older um just to realize
that hey I'm getting all this and and
the cool part is I my most my career has
been spent hanging drywall and doing
metal framing not the easiest way to go
through uh construction but but it did
me well but you could also learn
flooring uh Hardware IND doors uh
ceiling you name it and it's not just
the apprentices not just new people
coming in for people like myself that
have been around a while I can learn how
to read prints uh I can do learn how to
become a foreman I can do other things
like that so I don't have to strap on
the tools and hang 12 put 58s all day um
so I just hate to see people miss that
opportunity that chance to be able to go
join whatever Union you want whether
it's any of the Building Trades because
they all have really great
apprenticeship programs and and not be
able to do that and like um
representative McKenzie said you know we
train them doesn't mean they got to stay
and and lots of people go and either
start their own businesses or work for
somebody else because maybe they don't
agree with the Union ways and that's
fine too that's fine too we know we've
developed some good people some strong
people some honest hopefully Hest
hardworking people and we'd like to
continue that tradition so obviously if
you haven't picked up I know I'm against
this stuff this bill but thank you okay
fair
enough represent Susi thank you Mr
chairman I just want to say that I
thought it was very compelling from the
individuals that came in to testify uh
um at the
hearing that this is actually going to
only affect a very small percentage of
companies in the state of New Hampshire
and everybody that was here that was
testifying that belonged to a union
seemed
happy for what the union was providing
for
them the only people that were here that
testified on this bill and it was said
that day where either a for
non-union employee the um witness from
Texas who worked for the police
department that was
non-union or they were public sector
employees which this with the Janice
decision really doesn't affect at this
point so when we're talking about what
this bill is going to
do for a very small percentage of people
in this state and here's the other thing
we didn't see anybody other than the
nfib come in in state that all the small
businesses you know 85% or 80 to 85% of
the small businesses in the state are
against this but we had many companies
big companies in the state that afford
this
legislation so if we sit here today
we're going to try to pass this
legislation and I've been here this is
my this is going to be my eth term I was
a union guy I was a president of a union
for nine years dealing with this and
then I came to the legislature and we're
still dealing with it
for a very small amount of people that
this is going to create a problem for
which I feel that it's not creating a
problem because there wasn't one person
that came in here again that belonged to
one of these unions out here that was
disturbed by this
legislation so once again folks I I
think this is bad legislation I don't
think it's needed um I think we could
move forward with it without it and as
somebody said earlier there aren't
companies lined up here we just saw an
article the other day about a company
that was coming in here nothing to do
with right to work but they're going to
employ 500 people moving in from
Massachusetts they didn't say anything
about they're coming here because New
Hampshire may become a right to work
state so I'd say like representative lir
I think you know where I stand so thank
you Roger that yes
ma'am thank you Mr chair um yesterday
some of us Democrats were speaking about
what we might say or could say on this
issue and I said oh I'd like to talk
about about you know the ministers and
the moral argument and the thought then
from some was well you're not going to
change any Minds I do agree with
representative Granger we probably all
know how we're going to vote before we
got in here today but I do think it's
important to voice in my
opinion uh the morality of this the fact
that all labor has dignity and um a hero
to me is Martin Luther King Jr the
Reverend Martin Luther King Jr um and he
said to parap phrase uh right to work
neither increases rates nor improves
anything for workers and he said where
these laws have been passed wages are
lower job opportunities are fewer and
there are no civil
rights um to me that gets to the Crux of
it it is a human right to organize your
workplace um we had a number of
ministers Testify the um group people
with the organization faith and labor
New Hampshire Council of churches and a
whole bunch of religions that don't
agree on a lot of things politically
let's be honest but they all agree that
this bill is not the way to take New
Hampshire or really anywhere in America
but in New Hampshire um and to me that
has meaning I can tell you about all the
members of my family tree that are labor
unions or the my experience working for
labor unions all that is irrelevant to
the bigger moral piece in my opinion so
hopefully that's helpful to to somebody
that's listening and I felt I needed to
give voice to that here given how many
people did testify from that point of
view thank you Mr chair thank you I
appreciate that representative Schultz
any other questions comments
representative Granger thank you Mr
chair simply put the ethics of it are
very simple I don't care how good a deal
is I have a I want the right to say no
and that's what this legislation is
no are there any comments
from the
committee was that
Solan thank you Mr chairman um I won't
prolong this um I will say that I'm
proud of all the statements that my
caucus members have made I agree with
all of them and I will be opposing the
you all right so everyone has had a
chance to say their
Ro representative avalani yes
representative
zero
yes representative Prout yes
representative Warden
yes representative
drgo
yes representative Granger
I representative Hall yes
representative
lebrin
yes representative Sullivan no
representative uh kahill no
representative D sylvestro no
representative Susi no representative
Bard no representative McKenzie no
representative Schultz no Representative
no you have to you have to say your vote
yes and then my oh and representative
vote 10 yay n nay okay and um so this
and for the majority
Granger uh yep I'll have that over to
you okay and uh we need and for the
minority I'll okay we we do need it um
by noon tomorrow at the absolute latest
so if you can get it to me before we
walk out that's my that's what I
normally do um but at the latest noon
tomorrow all
right that closes the executive session
69 and HB 69 represented Warren do we
have a motion yes I move inexpedient to
legislate the motion is inexpedient to
legislate do we have a second on that
motion M second representative McKenzie
second
and would you like to speak to your
motion sure we've heard this bill a
number of years and it seems like an
undue burden on small businesses that
already have to comply with law in
regards to checking the uh status
citizenship ability to work social
security card and ID of employees so
it's just an extra layer and I think
we've already piled on enough to the
employers of New Hampshire and I've I
also don't like tying things we do here
to uh the feds because that that can
change on moment's notice so that's why
I am encouraging an expedient to
legislate for this legislation all right
and representative McKenzie would you
like to speak to your motion okay is
there anyone else that would like to
bill seeing no further discussion uh Mr
representative
avalani yes representative
Sero
yes uh yes sorry representative Warden
yes representative Drago
yes representative Granger hi
representative Hall yes representative
kessing yes representative
L
yes representative Sullivan yes
representative kahill yes representative
D sylvestro yes representative Susi yes
representative busard yes representative
McKenzie yes representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stab
yes it's
and representative
kraton I okay be
unanimous and is there any objecting to
consent seeing no objection please put
calendar and represent Warden you got
that closes the executive session on HB
69 we'll now open the executive session
on hb3
353 relative to hearing protection for
employees of nightclubs and music
venues Mr
chair yes sir so as a sponsor of
legislation I would uh move to
inexpedient to legisl at this point I'll
speak to that you would move to what
inexpedient to legislation okay and do
we have a second on that I'll second
that representative Warden seconds would
you like to speak to your motion I would
um I think that there is an issue uh not
only about nightclubs but generally uh
people are being
subjected uh to very high hearing uh
very high noise levels the OSHA uh has
jurisdiction in the private sector they
have rules and regulations naos has uh
stuff that people can take advantage of
Unfortunately they don't enforce it um
we have no jurisdiction as a as a state
legislature over oer or the federal
environment so this really has got to be
confined to the to the local um to State
Employees and to that end I have been in
touch with the Department of Labor they
are willing to have a discussion about
this and potentially propose some kind
of um there's already language in the
law but maybe enhanced the language it's
in the law and I think that's probably
the best way to go so that's uh that's
the reason I asked that this be
inexpedient I I appreciate it it's a it
is an important issue and and I hope you
can come up with something that that's
workable thank you are there any other
legislation saying no comments Mr clerk
can you call the rooll Mr chair could
you repeat the motion the motion is itl
thank you
so we're saying yay to
itl representative avalani
yes representative Sero yes
representative Prout yes representative
Warden yes representative Drago yes
representative Granger
I representative Hall yes representative
kessing yes representative
lbre yes representative Sullivan yes
representative k H yes representative D
sylvestro yes representative Susi yes
representative bushard yes
representative McKenzie yes
representative Schultz yes
representative lir yes representative
stab yes okay and representative
kraton I hey can we have the the
committee clerk announced his own vote
for the record did you y he did did been
doing it now in my name when I get to it
perfect I'm sorry didn't hear it I
didn't do it on the first vote okay okay
good point and is there any objection to
putting this on
consent seeing no objection please put
consent report and represent McKenzie
you yes closes the hearing on HB
353 or correction the executive session
on HB 353 I'm now opening the executive
1228 and representative Granger do we
have a motion yes Mr chairman I uh move
we
retain the motion is to retain is there
chairman and the second representative
Granger would you like to speak to your
motion thank you
uh we just need I I think there's some
more information that we can glean from
this and um if we retain it we might be
able to get all the information without
actually having to pass it on floor vote
simple so the idea about retaining is
that we would then have an opportunity
to look closer at this bill and um we
also we already have um um
representative lab's agreed to help
representative Granger look into it is
there anyone else that would like to
look into this bill uh with
Granger
please so we're looking to study the
unemployment
system what does that mean re Granger
can you answer that please yes it means
finding out the answers to all the
questions that are listed out in the
bill
I have a question warning if we vote to
retain it does that mean it's not
reported to the clerk yet or it doesn't
go on the calendar and we have until
what crossover to deal with
it or is it different than interim study
that's that was my question so interim
study is a second term and retain is the
first term and the first term it can
roll over into the second term and then
be resurrected in a new form based on
the results of the committee do I have
that right yeah the um retained Bill uh
it's intended to be worked on prior to
the next um uh January session and we
would vote on all of retained bills on
the first day of session in next January
um can I please um and I guess um I'm
going to vote against retaining okay and
my rationale is that um this studying um
if it's desirable and I respect um
representative Granger's interest in the
issue his interest in studying the issue
but I don't believe the uh the committee
um
I this this type of insurance is deeply
embedded in
government um it it is a federal state
um uh cooperation that creates it
it follows a lot of federal rules um and
uh there's there's a lot that goes back
and forth between the department of of
um uh Employment Security and the the
federal government I I believe that's of
Great Value I don't I have no interest
in seeing this privatized in any way um
therefore um while I respect
representative Granger's interest and I
would encourage him to go ahead and
study uh um but um I don't believe the
committee should be sponsoring that
study um so therefore I'm going to vote
against
retaining okay fair enough are there any
other comments or discussions regarding
motion Mr chairman if I could represent
McKenzie so I uh I sered for a number of
years on the unemployment advisory
committee which is a place where people
can come and ask questions and get
things it's open to the public this this
has been open to the public for years
you have an opportunity to go there and
and and ask all kinds of question
anything you want to know uh and they
you have a whole entire staff of of that
group there so I think that there's
opportunities to get answers to
questions I know that the Department of
Employment security has been very open
uh Deputy Commissioner labors has been
very open to the legislature answering
questions you might have um so I think a
lot of that could be resolved out side
of retain a retain Bill and uh while I
volunteered far I would probably vote uh
and will vote against retaining it and
uh and happy to work with uh with
anybody to uh to get better informed
about the about the unemployment system
as a group you know happy to work with
anybody on that so represent grer the
the uh the commitment in my mind so I
and I I I think about this with interim
study and with retain bills is the
commitment that the the work will go on
in terms of trying to
finish the research associated with
putting together a quality
legislation and
uh your commitment to making that happen
with the assistance of two other members
on the
committee uh it's your assessment that
you can come up with something that uh
is reasonable given that the testimony
of what we've heard this
morning yeah I think that we can come up
with something and we can um either
modify the bill based on our research or
at least provide the answers to the
questions and if we can provide an
answer to those questions to members of
the committee then uh and we don't see
the need for further legislation then I
would make the motion to itl the bill in
the second year however if if um
hopefully we get the answers to the
questions and uh the fact that we are
retaining it and we have a subcommittee
working on it would probably assist with
that greatly um as as I said I was
trying to research this and I reached
out to a very many a large amount of
resources and I was not able to get the
answers uh I believe if we retain it in
committee we can get those
answers okay um subject to your
commitment uh to that work um I I can
support a rain although I completely
understand the the detractors on the
other side but uh if you can get
something done then let's see what
happens I'm I'm okay with that thank you
Mr chair are there any other comments
questions Mr CLK can you call the role
please and the the motion is to retain
so a yay means that we want to retain a
nay means we do not want to
retain representative avalani yes
representative Siro yes representative
Prout yes representative Warden yes
representative drgo yes representative
Granger hi representative Hall yes
representative kessle ring yes
representative
labre yes representative Sullivan no no
Representative kahill no representative
D sylvestro no represent resentative
Susi no representative Bard no
representative McKenzie no
representative Schultz no Representative
lir no representative stab no and
I the vote is uh 10 y n n okay uh very
good and this closes the executive
1228 um on a in terms of a
subcommittee uh representative Granger
representative lbre and representative
McKenzie I would appreciate your help
and your expertise if you could do if
you could do that thank you sir okay and
so representative Granger you've got the
chair of the
subcommittee you got the chair of the
subcommittee and uh I look forward to
your
results thank you Mr
chair and are there is there any other
order of business we've got an 11:00
hearing scheduled so we got about 20
minutes representative Schultz I just
want to say it's great to see you
representative that you're walking in
here I'm glad to see you here thank you
thank you I'm all fine so no worries you
are all fine or you're not all fine I'm
good no worries all right great thank
glad here your car not
so okay so uh we'll recess until 1100
hours if you could be here promptly
we've got a busy day ahead of us I
appreciate all the work this morning
much
C right yeah he said they're going to
delay it until February 4th and I
normally print up all
my bills Mr chair
question yes sir do we need a motion to
postpone HB 225 to next week or do we
just as far as I know we do not okay
that's a it's a my discretion on whether
we listen to it that's a great question
thank
you
um and McKenzie are doing
The Minority Report on
23 we don't know which one yet they're
out so it was in there from last week
your
cheats what was that you should be
okay okay that's I'm just go the way
it's on the sheet she the Sheet's wrong
okay it was throwing me off to go to him
last so that's why I know that yeah for
sure me than you that's how it was
that's how it should be okay that's not
how here but I can definitely remember
that so the next question on this for
majority and our Minority Report who was
it that said that they're writing the is
that for 238 yes 238 it's either lir or
or
McKenzie
e
morning everyone I'd like to open the
hearing on HB 282 increasing the maximum
benefits for First Responders critically
injured in the line of duty and
representative Susi uh as the co-sponsor
would you like to introduce this bill
please I would thank you Mr chairman for
the record uh representative Tim Susi
represent conquer
um so I'm here to introduce House Bill 8
uh 282 FN the bill increases the maximum
total compensation paid to all claimants
for First Responders critical injury
benefits from 500,000 to $1 million per
bium and I would love to answer
questions but I think there's people
behind me that are do a better job of
answering them so thank
you and seeing no questions thank you
ril thank you
sir if you could state your name and who
you represent for the record
sure thank you Mr chair honorable
members of the committee for the record
my name is Brian will I serve as the
president of the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire we
represent approximately 2,000 active and
retired firefighters across the granite
state I appreciate you allowing me the
opportunity to speak this morning on
House Bill 2 82 uh which would increase
the maximum benefits for First
Responders critical injured critically
injured in the line of duty um as you're
all well aware our profession the
inherent risks associated with
firefighting continue to evolve over
time and although there's considerable
evolution in firefighting policies
procedures best practices and personal
protective equipment the fact remains
that the dedicated firefighters that
protect this state and their communities
are constantly at risk for catastrophic
injury a devastating illness or death um
and I'd like to share a a short anecdote
with you um just the other night I also
serve as a a fire captain in the city of
Portsmouth um just the other night my
members responded to a 9-year-old child
in Cardiac Arrest um and they treated
that patient uh and they treated that
patient with professional
professionalism and due diligence um and
as a result of that uh it was determined
that it's possible that this patient
passed away due to uh
menitis and and um our members were
subsequently exposed to that during
their Airway treatments um this bill
should my my members be affected um by
that illness would help to cover them uh
and protect them with uh the the benefit
so as current law stands um a claimant
that suffers an impairment to their
heart lungs brain or internal organ or
their senses also has an opportunity in
a addition to their workers comp
benefits up to
$125,000 benefit uh for an impairment to
one of these organs or to their
senses uh the law currently states that
this will allow a benefit up to $500,000
for all claimants over a banum uh this
simply would increase that to $1 million
and although uh we have not reached that
$500,000 cap as you'll see in the
methodology of the bill
um it is in large part due to the fact
that this is a lesser known benefit that
we need to do a better job of educating
our members on um and with the evolving
risks of the job uh it is easily uh one
can easily come to the conclusion that
this benefit will be paid out more over
time um and over the course of 10 years
since this benefit was enacted uh has
not changed from the
$500,000 uh for the bium so with that um
it's just a a simple uh technical change
that obviously comes with a financial
impact and I would ask um that all the
members of this committee respectively
uh would vote in favor of this bill and
I'm happy to answer any questions you or
the committee may have Mr chair thank
you representative
Sullivan thank you Mr chairman um thank
you for taking my question the
$125,000 that uh can be you said up to
$125,000 can be paid out what determines
how much of that uh 125 is paid out EXA
what does it cover sure thank you um I
will tell you that there's someone here
that's going to testify that'll be able
to answer that question a little bit
more clearly for you but I'm going to
take a stab at it um to my knowledge it
works in large part dependent upon um
the organ that is injured what the
individual salary is at the time uh and
they're assigned a formula uh that deals
with the number of weeks um that is
calculated for that injury for that
organ and the benefit is paid out
somewhere
injury yes you got
it representative
Granger uh thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking my questions so I'm
seeing from 281 a32 that this was it it
you can correct me if I'm wrong about
this if you if you happened to know if
not then that's fine I uh that this was
put in place on in 2014 and last
modified in
2017 do you know if we dur since this
has ever been put in place if we have
ever hit that half million dollar cap so
I do not believe we have and I'm only
speaking uh from the methodology that
came with the bill um and when they
looked at the cost of this I believe the
highest payout over banum was $350,000
and that was in um I believe
2023 thank you sure
represent Warden thank you thank
you am I reading the statutes correctly
this is in addition to other existing
workers compensation that's based on the
type of injury and the number of weeks
that a person that's harmed or injured
gets uh compensated for for
example permanent loss or impairment of
heart lung or brain which I think you
were talking about the lungs that if
somebody suffers that injury that they
automatically get 200 eight up to 28
weeks of compensation which is four
years and that this would be in addition
to that other uh paid compensation is do
I have that right correct and this is uh
specific to First Responders critical
injury it is a an additional benefit due
to them but under uh
281 I believe that anyone has access to
the first piece that you were speaking
of this would be in addition to that for
specifically for First
Responders repres kale thank you thank
you Mr chair and thank you for taking my
question um if uh if I recall correctly
this legislation was created in response
to the shooting of a sergeant Dy of
Manchester police uh who was had several
wounds abominable wounds in the uh in
the Coline of Duty uh and I know we were
all rush to vote for that and I expect
we'll vote we'll vote for this but
um is it the idea that with you know
more more people becoming aware of it
and medical costs getting higher and
higher that we need to raise this
cap well I think that's um a fair
question thank you uh certainly I would
be in favor of raising that cap um but I
guess that would be for all of you to to
make that determination thank you
thanks are there any other questions
representative
McKenzie Mr President thank you for
appearing for this committee so what is
to reach back on uh on this onund on the
25,000 for claim it what is what is the
reach I'm not sure I understand your
question you asking if there would be
retroactive payments made yeah
somebody's um to my knowledge it does
not specify that in the language I'm not
sure that there would be a retroactive
payment anyone do um maybe the uh I
don't know if okay we have somebody else
that might be able answer that question
for you thank you Mr chair okay thank
you and represent Granger thank you Mr
chair uh so look looking at this section
I'm just trying to understand existing
law if there's someone else that can
answer these question I don't want to
put you on the spot or anything I so it
so we have permanent loss or impairment
of heart long or brain 208 permanent
loss of or impairment of other internal
organs 104 so is that additive so if you
have a problem with your heart lung or
brain and then another internal organ
208 it's okay if you don't know I don't
yeah I don't know the answer I I was
raing to see if I could decide for the
the response to it but no I don't I
don't have an answer for that thank
you representative Drago thank you Mr
chair you mentioned trying to get more
people um aware of this benefit to take
advantage of it do you know how many
people how many injuries what percentage
actually do take care of it now or use
this benefit now I don't have a
percentage for you but I I can tell you
just based on again the the bill
methodology from the Department of Labor
and their statistics have shown that um
only there was the highest amount paid
out per Bay name was
350,000 which means if uh and I believe
two of those to the best of my knowledge
were maxed out at
125,000 um which means it was probably
only two or or there was probably only
three or four people that got paid out
highest are there any other
questions seeing none thank you sir I
appreciate your testimony thanks so much
please good morning Mr chairman uh
members of the committee my name is
Jared o' Conor uh I'm an attorney with
the firm of of Shaheen and Gordon um and
I've spent about 20 years representing
Injured Workers in workers compensation
claims it's the sole focus of my
practice um I represent a broad Suite of
clients but uh in the last I would say
five to seven years in particular my
focus has been on First Responders um so
I'm here in favor of the bill and I'm
really here to offer myself as a
resource for questions about some of the
technical aspects of the law so let me
see if I've written down and can address
them one by one uh represent Sullivan
you had asked about how this is
calculated so under the law you can see
that uh depending on the nature of the
injury or the nature of the body part
that's injured there are a number of
weeks worth of benefits assigned to each
body part when I say weeks worth of
benefits I mean the benefit that this
individual worker is entitled to which
is calculated based on their own average
weekly wage so higher earning claimants
have a higher average weekly wage lower
earning claim CL it's obviously the
reverse so somebody with a average
weekly wage of let's just make the math
easy 500 bucks a week if they get hund
well now I'm not going to be able to do
the math in my head but you get the idea
if it's a small number um and they're
entitled to8 weeks worth of benefits
because of an injury to an internal
organ then they may only reach 60,000 of
the
$125,000 cap whereas someone who is a
higher earner um May well exceed and I
have had clients who do I've represented
firefighters with significant Burns over
portions of their body where they lose
the ability to touch or have sensation
under this uh my client the one I'm
thinking of was maxed out at 125,000
because his average weekly wage was
fairly High um so that's how it's
calculated does that answer your
question okay um representative McKenzie
you had asked about the retroactivity
piece of
this okay all right fair enough
uh and then let's see representative
Maguire you had
asked oh whether it was additive if you
have a brain injury and also a shot to
the pancreas can you include those I
think if you look at the language of the
statute yes I think you could however
they're still both collectively subject
to the
$125,000 cap so if you have somebody
with a particularly low average weekly
wage who is entitled to multiple Awards
under this section if you scan down to
the section of the law under Section 32A
Roman 2 payments under this section are
subject to everything else in workers
comp and total compensation shall not
exceed under this section 125,000 per
claimant so if they do have multiple
cap representative
Warden thank you thank you this is very
helpful for understanding the statute or
interpreting it so on on the worst type
of injuries which is heart lung and
brain 208 weeks which is four years we
don't have to break it down by week 52
weeks is one year 28 weeks is uh four
years so if the employee makes $100,000
a year and he is entitled to up to four
years the max he can get is
$125,000 or does he get four years 4 a
grand plus the 125 no the max is
$125,000 and just just so you know how
it works because it's based on their
workers compensation disability rate if
they're making $100,000 a year under
workers comp when you're out on
disability you get 60% of your average
weekly wage so they would be entitled to
60,000 a year if they're out on comp if
they're entitled to four years worth of
benefits under this provision that would
be 240,000 so they're they're going to
hit the cap and get 125 in a case like
that that's super helpful thank you
represent k Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question so uh the legislation
proposed does not raise the 125 cap it
only allows more money to be available
should there be some sort of
catastrophic situation where multiple
First Responders have severe injuries
correct what this legislation does is
just broaden the pool right now each
individual is capped at 125 the pool is
500 so you have five four claimants and
it's exhausted um but yes this would
broaden the pool but each individual
person wouldn't be entitled to more than
125 under this thank you representative
Granger uh thank you Mr chair so when
I'm reading this it says in addition to
other payments made under RSA 281 so it
I understand that the 125k is in
addition to other workman's comp payouts
correct yeah this provision is sort of a
standalone benefit available only to
group two retirement members meaning
police and fire so this is only
available to them and it's payable in
addition to whatever else they're
entitled to underw workers comp because
they're entitled to everything that
regular citizens are entitled to you
know the regular medical benefits
disability benefits there is a permanent
impairment award that is available to
ordinary claimants but it's limited to
primarily physical type Orthopedic
injuries if you are a you know a do
worker or you're working at Walmart and
you have a serious injury if that injury
is to your internal organs there is no
per an impairment award available
broadly speaking to workers compensation
claimants what this benefit does is
create that benefit for specifically
group two retirement members and it is
as you say in addition to whatever else
they may be entitled to under workers
comp can I get a followup yes please uh
what is what is there a cap on what the
typical amount so if you're not a first
responder and you're on on and you're
covered by
281 what is is there a cap on how much a
single person can get out uh the there
there is a cap it's set by the amount of
weeks that are assigned to each body
part if so if you look at section 32 of
the law that's the permanent impairment
provision broadly speaking and what that
does is it assigns a number of weeks
worth of disability benefits to each
body part so your arm is worth 210 weeks
worth of benefits and your little finger
is nine and your leg is 140 and on and
on it goes I know this is what this is
the Facebook found it's pretty mobber
thank you very much right so so that so
the cap there is just the amount of
weeks there's no monetary cap for
individual claimants the way there is
with this thank you okay and
representative Hall he's he's covered
mine okay good and representative
library and then represent you may or
may not know this qu the answer to this
question where does the union stand with
all this in terms of benefits somebody
would receive in in the in the case of
an accident or long-term disability
we're just coming off a union discussion
here and we we've heard that they they
help and and maybe somebody else could
answer it but would you know someone
probably else would better answer that
than me but I would imagine I just
wanted to see how that's stacked on top
of this I mean it this benefit is
payable separate from whatever else the
union May provide this is payable out of
the general fund from the state so it's
not it's not assigned to or payable by
the individual City municipality or
Insurance Company this is just an
entirely separate benefit that comes out
of the general fund I was just trying to
find out what that benefit may be yeah
thank you sure yeah representative
avalani thank you Mr chairman thank you
for taking the question um on this 125
per claimant um is that subject
to your
fee in yes it
is and that is 20% attorney's fees are
capped at 20% in these cases thank
you represent waren question on the
mechanics of the payment if somebody
qualifies for so many weeks of this
additional compensation
after he or she has been
injured does uh the claimant receive a
lump sum and he gets to stop working or
is it paid out over so many months once
it's been approved so the the mechanics
of this are that if the claimant has a
permanent impairment so it does need to
be permanent um once that's demonstrated
to the satisfaction of the labor
department the labor department
certifies the benefit as a critical
injury benefit and then sends it over to
the executive Council which then
approves the payment out of the general
fund the payment is made in one lump
sum followup for a followup thank you
that is helpful thank you and then often
the pur person's not working anymore
that's separate issue right they this
comes from the general fund because he's
no longer he or she's no longer employed
potentially most likely not necessarily
I mean it's certainly possible for
people to have a permanent injury that
nevertheless Isn't So severe that it
keeps them from working I mean you can
have permanent loss of some function or
some loss of range of motion and still
hold down a job um so it's not it's not
necessarily A Ono one I mean in many
cases obviously yes the injury is severe
enough that they need to retire from the
force or from the Department um but it's
not necessarily the case it's good of a
subject matter expert here thanks
sure are there any other
questions so I've got a question on one
second let me uh well go ahead rent grer
go ahead I was just going to ask for a
card or
something absolutely we can get that can
you provide a business card to the
committee I can thank you and uh so I I
got two questions one might be out of
your purview but from your understanding
the the money comes out of the workers
comp
fund no okay so where does it come from
it comes out of the general fund out of
the general fund correct okay out of the
stage general fund correct okay so this
does not affect for example Prim X's
rates or each any any individual
municipalities workers compensation
rates this even though it the statute is
contained within the workers comp
statute right um and it's defined by a
lot of the same kinds of issues in
workers comp it's paid separately from
workers comp it's paid out of the
general fund okay and so my second
question is if the maximum that we've
done that we know of is
350,000 and the maximum currently in
statute is 150,000 more than that
500,000 then why do we have to go up to
a million I I'm I'm lost on that a
little bit so as a as a practical matter
as Mr R mentioned previously I think in
part this because this statute is it's a
fairly new benefit um it really only
took effect I I heard 2014 referenced
but my memory was that it pass in 2017
it can take a while for these cases to
work their way through the system
somebody has an initial injury they
treat for a year or two it's not clear
that they are permanently impaired for
some time after that then it's submitted
for approval so it a awareness of the
benefit as something that's even
available to First Responders is still I
think percolating its way through um the
state and just the nature of the cases
is such that it can take a while for
people to reach the point where they are
eligible to be rated for a permanent
impairment and so I think it's not
surprising to me for example that for
the first few years maybe even the first
four or five years that it was in
existence there wasn't many claims made
against the fund because people weren't
eligible for it until 2017 and it wasn't
until some years after that that we're
now starting to see them be applied for
okay so
good represent K thank you Mr chair and
thank you again for taking my question
so in the event that there are no
injuries of this type no claims then the
money stays in the general fund is not
doesn't cost anybody anything is that
correct correct thank
you okay seeing no further questions
thank you sir I appreciate your
testimony thank
you and Daniel um Miss Albert come on up
good morning thank you my name is
Danielle Albert I'm the Deputy
Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Labor um the department
has reviewed the proposed language
that's associated with this bill we
understand the intent um specifically in
raising the dollar amount available for
this particular benefit from the current
$500,000 amount to the $1 million amount
um we believe we can administer and
regulate uh as written and primarily
here are are here to answer any
questions I attorney OK Conor I believe
has answered quite a few of them but any
additional questions um that there may
be um I will perhaps start by addressing
one of the questions that was raised um
relative to um the the the cap as well
as the total dollar amount uh that was
that has been paid out historically um
as noted in the Department's fiscal note
to our knowledge the highest amount that
was ever paid out in any given bium year
was
$350,000 relative to volume of what the
department receives regarding these uh
requests for this particular benefit um
I don't have firm numbers I'm happy to
get them if that's something that's
helpful for the committee but on average
it's about two to maybe three per year
um my recollection is that this per
section of Statute went into effect in
2014 and I believe there was a sunset
provision in it that may have been
removed in
2017 um I'm I'm stretching my memory
back away so um that but that's my my
general recollection um and just to
emphasize attorney oconor did an
excellent job explaining it this is a
benefit that is not provided through the
regular workers
compensation um scheme in the sense that
the insurance carrier Andor insurance
policy is not paying for this benefit it
is 100% general fund funded and can be
uh paid to uh qualifying or eligible
injured worker in addition to all other
workers compensation benefits that that
individual is entitled to so if the
injured work worker uh injured first
responder is let's say still working in
some capacity they have a permanent
impairment or um a permanent injury that
qualifies under Section 32 of the
statute they uh are eligible to they're
eligible to receive all of that in
addition to this benefit if they qualify
so there's no offset or impact on other
benefits that are paid for under the
more traditional benefit scheme uh by
being eligible for this benefit and I am
happy to take any questions if there are
any representative Hall uh thank you for
taking my question do you have any uh do
you know how many potential cases are in
the pipeline now not yet resolved that
may trigger us hitting the
max any potential cases that are in the
pipeline that are not yet resolved do
you by do you mean that the that
petition has been made to the department
for certification for the benefit I'm
not aware currently of any pending I
would I'm happy to double check with Our
Workers Compensation Division uh just to
assure that something hasn't very
recently come in but as far as I'm aware
I do not believe that there are any
currently pending thank you okay any
other questions represent avalani thank
you Mr chairman good to see you again
Deputy Commissioner um so this is on top
of everything that workman's comp would
pay out so if workman's comp paid out
for a loss of limb um for a Public
Employee they would also pay out under
this as well that is is correct assuming
or uh contingent upon one the injured
individual meeting the eligibility
criteria that they are the they meet the
definition of first responder they a
group to retiree uh that they have uh
that the department has certified them
as having a permanent injury that's at
less than 100% so there are certain
eligibility criteria attendant to this
benefit should the first responder meet
those eligibility criteria yes this
benefit would be paid on top of lost
time from work medical benefits um the
more traditional permanent impairment
award any other comp benefit that's out
there follow it Mr chairman please um on
the private sector is there a similar um
process for that or is it just that
you're one andone with the workman's
comp and you're back to work there is no
secondary level of uh Insurance that's
an excellent question so for the private
sector for any injured worker who does
not qualify as a first responder defined
by the comp statute there is no
comparable critical injury benefit uh
the benefits would be the um there is a
permanent impairment benefit that's
available set forth at section 32 that's
the scheduled table that attorney OK
Conor referenced um for certain types of
bodily injury um to the the individual's
person but the critical injury benefit
I'm not aware there's no
comparable thank you thank you Mr
chairman representative Granger uh thank
you Mr chair is so if if the first
responder dies does this apply or no or
is that a separate section of law or
um that's a very good question I think
it's arguable I'd have to look at that a
little bit more closely there are
separate death benefits that are
available to the dependence of a
deceased injured worker whether they're
a first responder or not that's um
essentially the monetary weekly payment
for lost wages
um I'm happy to look at that a little
further I don't want to give an answer
that's inaccurate so if if you're
comfortable with me going back I would
just like to look at the statute in
detail and provide an answer on it if
you could provide it for the whole
committee I greatly appreciate
absolutely thank you yes please thank
you yes all right seeing no further
questions thank you ma'am I appreciate
your testimony very welcome thank you
please State for the record your name
and who you represent of course thank
you Mr chairman for the record my name
is Bob blazel I represent the New
Hampshire state employees Association uh
thank you for your time I wasn't
planning on testifying however um
hearing some of the things I did I I
felt uh needed uh to say a few words
um this this statute I was just telling
uh to my good friend Jim deur here in
the back um this is one of the best
things we did um back in 2014 doing this
for Dan dhy
um because it was
needed and I will tell you getting it
through the house and the Senate um it
mod it had to be modified quite a bit as
you see the cap and whatnot there was a
couple of speed bumps at the time um
there was a sunset provision that was
mentioned earlier
um this is critical this is really
really important and I can tell you the
125,000 okay I still keep in touch with
Dan it's not even close
it's not even
world what I'd like you to think
about is what if there were five Dand
dores God
forbid what happens to that fifth
person Dan got
$125,000 that was the max he could get
should have got
more what do you say to that fifth
person in a
catastrophic AC
ENT we all know what happens all the
time all all these you know gun violence
throughout the country what
happens this is this is pretty important
stuff so I would just ask you what do
you do with the fifth person and as this
and I fully support this legislation by
the way expanding this to a million
absolutely but Mr chairman you mentioned
well if there's only
350,000 that was that was the highest in
one year why don't we just put why don't
we just put
500 I would challenge you and the rest
of this committee to maybe think why
even have a cap at
all let's use that
logic right nobody here has a crystal
ball nobody knows what's going to happen
today tomorrow but we have a
responsibility we have a a real
responsibility to those men and women
who come to our Aid I fully support the
bill cuz I know these sort of things you
got to take it and baby so I really
really uh appreciate the the the uptick
from 500 to a million it's
important um but I just want you to
think about that fifth person right now
or as this is read that that ninth
person but this is this is moving the
needle and I fully support it and I hope
questions
rivan thank you for your testimony um
it it occurs to me that if New Hampshire
had a New Hampshire sized version of 911
would a million dollars be
enough not even close thank
you all right thank you sir I appreciate
up okay seeing no more pin cards I just
philosophically um
what we think about in this committee is
policy is this the right thing to do
okay this has got a fiscal note on it so
by the 6th of March it's got to go to
the finance and they figure
out yeah it's the right thing to do
because the committee said it's the
right thing to do but can we afford it
so there's two separate questions we're
answering the first question and as we
think we'll exact this next week so as
we think through that just recognize
that we're the policy guys it's should
make sense but the actual determination
if we can afford it goes to the finance
committee are there any
representative I do have one question
for the prime sponsor is it appropriate
to ask him to come back for one question
uh he's not here but representative
Susie wants to I probably could not
answer that ask okay all right okay okay
important question and I I need I need
ask question okay the question is where
do the union stand with the with the
compensation for injuries I need to know
please and please state your name again
for the record sure thank you again uh
my name is Brian re I represent the
professional firefighters of New
Hampshire um we represent 42 local
firefighter unions throughout the state
um if I'm understanding your question
correctly are you asking if there is a
benefit provided by the unions in
addition to
this Mr chair please I am I'm I want
want to know what where the purview is
with the with the unions where do they
what's their scope of payment or uh
supplement or something to you know
somebody gets hurt or or God forbid
killed so we not being the employer of
each individual member um we don't
provide a critical injury benefit at all
um however with that being said many if
not most local unions have their own
charitable associations in existence we
as a professional firefighters of New
Hampshire have uh what we call the
Fallen firefighters family fund where we
help take care of our members and their
families should a catastrophic incident
happened um but it is not anything that
we can provide any significant benefit
um up to in including $125,000 benefit
um usually these charitables help with
things such as um getting a member
lodging down at a uh a hospital or a
Trauma Center if they their family needs
to stay in AAL hotel or getting them
travel to some place um to help them get
the care that they need we're helping
for instance we we help with their
families and their children and try and
help them through things like college we
send them um money should they're God
forbid their um father mother um be
killed in in the line of duty we send
them money every year to try and help
the children um but we do not have a
specific critical injury benefit for
this thank you sure
okay thank you so much I appreciate it
I'm sorry represent McKenzie do you have
sir can you answer one more question
please so I I just um if I could just uh
just State what we have been doing at
the national level uh in terms of a
death benefit for uh for fallen
firefighters because that's been an
initiative of the if for a number of
years sure thank you for the question um
so we are you referring to the public
safety officers benefit yeah so there is
a federal Public Safety officers benefit
um should someone tragically die in the
line of duty U As A Firefighter and I
believe that should they meet that
metric and and meet all the
qualifications for that it's somewhere
in excess of $450,000 benefit paid to
the families um obviously it's it's very
tragic landine of Duty death so that
money wouldn't be paid um to the member
but it would be paid to the familyes so
and that is something that the
International Association of
firefighters which is the um
International Union that represents us
um has has fought for uh at the federal
level for many many years um and that
benefit has slowly uh increased over
time thank you sure all right thank you
so much appreciate
it subject to no further questions or
comments uh I close this
hearing and we'll take a 10-minute
recess before we hear uh testimony on HB
what's all
right so what do we do we're right this
write the work together you can if you
want I mean you can we can call call me
later or you can talk about it or
a ice or
[Music]
something yeah but did you
just your fault I don't even
little
my play on the
both that way at least if I whichever
see
e
the many other hats that I wear is as an
Advisory Board member and facilitator
for the elephant in the room series of
the New Hampshire theater project in the
elephant in the room we use a scripted
play reading followed by a facilitated
discussion to talk about difficult
topics we've had them about opioid
epidemic we've had them about school
violence we've had them about human
trafficking but for the past two years
one of our major programs has been
specifically about pts and First
Responders during the discussion portion
of the program we've heard over and over
about the impact of repeated traumatic
incident exposure on our First
Responders that part was not at all a
surprise the part that was surprising
occurred when we had many of our First
Responders from small communities talk
about how difficult it is for them to
access Care Mental Health Care in
particular First Responders who
participated in the program shared
stories from being the dispatcher who
took the call about their own family
member and weren't allowed to leave work
in order to go address the situation to
those who were on the scenes of horrific
accidents where they had to literally
search for body parts that were no
longer
attached um to those who searched for
colleagues who had to search remote
locations for um colleagues with the who
had gone off with the intent of self
harm
um we also heard from family members and
Friends of First Responders who talked
about the long-term impact of the job on
their loved ones we also had a special
presentation for the New Hampshire and
Main Municipal Managers Association and
during that presentation we also heard
from um Town managers and town
administrators who wish they'd known how
to ensure that their Crews knew how to
access help but also those from small
very small communities who talked about
how difficult it was to find any funding
for that help um given how small their
communities were um and the limited
resources of those small communities
we also heard that although technically
workers comp is available to First
Responders who get injured on the job
and who have clearly medically Divine
defined
PTSD it's difficult to access and there
are limited supports for theirs who are
trying to work through their experiences
prior to getting to the stage of
full-blown PTSD right um one of the
consequences of all of this that we know
statistically nationally rates of
alcoholism substance abuse and suicide
are high very high among our first
responder populations um as well as
domestic violence increases as well in
many of those as a result of of the way
they handle their issues um larger towns
and cities across New Hampshire are
generally able to fund insurance for
their staff and include an EAP for them
as well an employee assistance program
which I know you know but maybe our
viewers at home don't um our smaller and
more remote towns are much more likely
to have volunteer uh firefighters they
may only have one police officer on
staff for their town they may have other
challenges but they are much less likely
to be able to fund that kind of care so
this bill was really designed to be the
stop Gap measure to fill the void to
fill the Gap in coverage by creating a
state funded EAP that specifically for
volunteer First Responders and those
from towns that have five or fewer paid
First Responders we can provide the C
coverage that's sorely needed it can be
accessed remotely for those who've
gotten to the level of having
significant PTSD it can also help
provide a specific diagnosis that makes
accessing workers comp easier more
accessible um I wanted to share a couple
of comments with you from some people um
one is by a career firefighter EMT who
attended our aftermath Workshop where we
talked about pts and First
Responders this meaning the aftermath
program was a little tough for me and
some of my former colleagues I've healed
but the wound is still sensitive I feel
the program is extremely valuable for
Community leaders to understand the
jovial first responder may have hidden
wounds that need attention I've been
called to a colleague's house at 2: a.m.
to look for my friend who is despondent
with a shotgun in the
woods sometimes a call hits too close to
home in time my nightmares have gone
away I'm
lucky sometimes it seems politicians
don't understand what public servants go
through um I'm going to also pass out to
you um an email that I received from
Genevie a
who's the founder of the elephant in the
room project where she adds additional
detail about some of the feedback we've
gotten from our program and then I also
wanted to share a couple of the um
comments that people posted in their
online
testimony um this one is from the town
of Lee um Dear honorable members of the
committee establishing an employee
assistance program for small town First
Responders oh the town of Lee is
supportive of this bill small
communities in New Hampshire have
limited resources and it's important
there are programs available for all
communities to assist with ISS issues
such as post-traumatic stress for fire
police EMS dispatch and DPW staff
involved in critical events Municipal
staff provides support to Citizens
concerning the most traumatic life
events events imaginable such as health
emergencies domestic disturbances fire
loss serious motor vehicle accidents
murders shootings Etc and should be
appropriately supported concerning their
mental health and well-being this bill
will ensure First Responders in small
communities receive the support they may
require that's from um Andy Robertson
who's the town manager in the town of
Lee um Richard Krauss who's from Fremont
I believe wrote this bill is necessary
for towns that do not properly offer
this program to its First Responders it
should be a Statewide um system for all
First Responders no matter what
community they're in and there's
additional comments online that I think
are valuable
um so um a couple of things so trying to
figure out how to figure out a cost for
this program I looked up how many First
Responders we have in New Hampshire I
divided that number by 50% and then I
multiplied it by the rough estimate of
what it cost to enroll a person in an
EAP so the idea being that obviously not
everyone's going to need to access this
care every year right ideally it's a
small number of people but hopefully
it's all covered by by the
$150,000 that um I've asked for um at
the same time I also looked up the cost
to hire and train police and
firefighters I didn't look at every type
of first responder that wasn't realistic
for me um but I would say that First
Responders also include people who work
in Fire and Rescue and other similar
groups um based on what I found online
and work that I did reaching out to some
different police Chiefs the current
average State cost to hire a new police
officer in New Hampshire including
recruiting and training is approximately
$70,000 per person and one of them told
me it can be up to
$150,000 per officer to hire someone um
for fire it's a much more complicated
formula because because some
firefighters are hired simply as
firefighters some are EMT some are emt's
paramedics there's all different levels
so the formula came out to about 10,000
to 20,000 just to get hired um and then
to begin starting to equip them and so
if we think about the cost of this
program versus the cost of hiring
retaining and
recruiting it's obviously much less
expensive to provide our First
Responders with critical mental health
care when they need it rather than
having to go back and try to find new
people especially at a time when we
vacancies across the state in all of
these areas and um with that I will end
my testimony and be happy to answer your
questions excellent thank you are there
any questions
comments right next to you sir
representative Alani thank you Mr
chairman and thank you representa taking
the questions um you know you mentioned
in your testimony that this would be an
affirm an affirmative action for a
workman's comp claim to go to EAP first
and then backtrack to the so what we
heard is so technically workers comp is
supposed to cover
PTSD however to get Workers Comp and
this is what we were heard hearing from
our First Responders directly so I may
not have at all 100% accurate to be fair
but was that in order to access workers
comp they had to have a medical
diagnosis in order to get a medical
diagnosis they need to have seen someone
in order to seen someone they had to
have a way to pay for the person so we
had one of our people who came to one of
our presentations talk about his
full-time job is as a gas station
attendant he makes $15 an hour and has
zero benefits he can't afford to go see
someone to begin the process to get the
care and he talked about that he's not
sure how much longer he can stay as a
volunteer firefighter in his community
because he's not sure how much longer
his body can physically handle the
stress of the
job so the goal was to try to figure out
a way in situation like that if there's
a program like this that he could access
maybe he could get the initial care he
needs and maybe it would ultimately lead
to something to him needing workers comp
but maybe it wouldn't but this would
fill at least the initial gap of getting
him care and maybe it would allow him to
stay you know maybe it would be
sufficient maybe he'd have two sessions
with an EAP personnel and we would go
from there this isn't intended to fix
everything it's just trying to plug a
hole follow yes follow thank you um and
it's administered by the EAP program and
they would make a medical diagnosis of
an employee and it public or private I'm
conf confused so so an EAP is designed
um to provide mental health care or
other care that people can access
remotely right and so the the goal of
this is really about figuring out ways
to access the mental health care without
stigma and and getting them the care
they
need and final yes what notification to
the employer um if they intend to go to
EAP looking for a diagnosis to be able
to file a claim because worker uh
employers have a limited amount of
window to file that claim with their
insurance company to say there might be
something coming or they might be on the
hook because it's past the window so um
eaps by Design are intended to be
confidential to protect employees um one
of the things that we also heard from
our police officers who attended is that
if they were to go the route of being U
of um seeking Mental Health Care
specifically for on the job trauma they
can lose their certification as police
officers which leaves many of them
so um an EAP by Design is is intended to
be confidential between the employee or
the volunteer in this case um and and
the EAP program that's what it would be
through the state as opposed to through
a specific town and
so um I'm not sure if I'm able to answer
your question fully and I'm sorry that
I'm not an expert in the field okay
thank you thank you Mr chairman okay any
further
questions thank you representative
please good morning I'm Mike laws I am
the director of the state of New
program so one of the things that I
would would try to be brief and maybe
leave the the more interactive piece
around um potential questions or
concerns uh one of the things that we
looked at is our capacity to support
this bill and so the state of New
Hampshire's employee assistance program
has seven uh full-time state employees
total and we currently serve All State
departments so health and human services
safety liquor really any any uh state
agency not only does the state employee
but their family members have have
access to us
um so the number we we weren't sure
about uh the particular amount of
potential clients that this bill was
covering and so I did some us me and
some of the folks uh on on the HHS side
did some research and part of what we
found out in particular there's a um
document that's referenced in the fiscal
note worksheet around uh Recruitment and
Retention report and recommendations
and the the numbers that we come up with
approximately in 2022 there were
4,256 on call or volunteer members of
fire departments throughout the state
and there also in some internal
correspondence with Department of Safety
in 2024 there were five uh fire
departments who reported having five or
less uh fire firefighters so I think in
that way just to be clear I'm
understanding that
as all volunteer firefighters would be
eligible under this bill as well as any
fire department that has five or less
full-time firefighters on staff and so
uh there were only five fire departments
with five or less firefighters on staff
but there's uh about 28% of the fire
departments did not answer that survey
so we we don't really know how many
additional uh clients from our
perspective would be eligible so we kind
of have that
4,256 as a starting number plus 25 plus
whoever didn't respond so in that way
the
um 150,000 appropriation wouldn't uh be
able to cover the costs of trying to
support even say between 6 and 10% most
eaps function at about 6% utilization
our current estimate are over 10% um but
if you think about even 6 to 10% of that
number accessing us particularly in
rural areas of the state where we may be
traveling or providing support trying to
find providers who you know for
currently while we serve all state
employees you know a high number of
those folks all have Anthem Insurance
what we're talking about here with this
group is we don't know what insurance
they have or if they have insurance and
the role we would play there would be uh
maybe connecting them with the provider
or Medicaid if they need uh resources
Beyond kind of temporary support with
EAP it wouldn't just be a kind of a
referral to a provider and and to the
previous uh testimony we don't diagnose
we don't diagnose so while some of our
uh folks on staff at the EAP are
licensed clinicians the EAP role in that
way would be more about uh providing
some support some education around a
critical incident or kind of the phys
physiological impacts or cognitive
emotional impacts but then referring
them to a trauma informed provider now
in my mind that that diagnosis that was
referenced say PTSD uh that's something
that could come from a clinical provider
in the community it could also come from
a medical provider and the role we might
play there would be helping them connect
with their PCP providing some
information and stabilization or helping
them connect with a clinical mental
health provider in the community but we
wouldn't be able to provide a DI di
agnosis based on their experience so I'm
long-winded I'll I'll kind of pause
there and and uh open it up if folks
have any questions I'm sorry are you in
favor of this bill opposed to it or
neutral I would say neutral in that way
I I think it's a great bill I apologize
for selecting I didn't know there was a
neutral option I guess I'm in favor of
it I think we're in favor of it but we
see that there's more of a financial
impact than was init initially kind of
addressed
schz so um thank you Mr chair I assume
firefighters who do have access to an
employee assistance program that don't
qualify for this because they have
already have access it's not through the
state it's must be through um maybe the
firefighters Union or another
Association maybe they local town oh
okay if I'm assuming if they have a
large enough employee group group a lot
of um private agencies are have elected
a private EAP perhaps okay um and and
they may be you know a provider a couple
of States over you know in turn I
brought some orientation material about
the EAP and kind of the breadth of our
services and also around how we respond
to critical incidents and things of that
nature our folks have all been trained
in critical incident stress management
um but some eaps are kind of a phone
number multiple States over whereas we
are internal residents of the state we
pride ourselves on resources and
Connections in the state if we provided
a mental health clinician in the
community we wouldn't just give you a
random number we check to make sure that
person has availability they accept your
insurance and we wouldn't give that name
unless we were comfortable with our own
family members accessing that employee
or that that clinician my apologies
representative Hall thank you Mr chair U
thanks for your testimony um we heard
from representative Cel when she
introduced the bill that one of the
hopes was that this program would help
get someone a diagnosis so that they
could um enter a workman's comp claim
but based on your testimony it doesn't
sound like this would help because EAP
programs don't do that kind of diagnosis
can you talk about yes I apologize for
jumping in um to the point of us
diagnosing no we wouldn't be able to
diagnose um that's not under our current
scope of practice and uh but what we
would do there and our familiarity you
know so where we serve All State
agencies you know we've worked with
folks who have had on the job injuries
right and so in that way we're familiar
with they the process that kind of
emerges in that uh so our role in that
particular incident let's say an
employee reached out or a firefighter
reached out they had an event we would
support and assess based on what they're
presenting with and I would imagine in a
situation like that part of the
conversation would also be around where
are their resources and and that bigger
umbrella is a resource that could
provide them a diagnosis and so at that
level it would be a PCP or a uh licensed
clinical mental health counselor in the
community which we have relationships
with folks like in those ways and so
from a referral process standpoint that
may be a much smoother transaction for
them but we could help them get
connected and kind of support them in
the in the process of getting connected
and dealing with the emotions and
experiences that they're dealing with in
the in the present moment quick followup
yes so there would still be an
additional benefit needed somewhere for
that person to get the diagnosis to go
into the workers's comp system it would
in that you know if they had insurance
we would quickly we' help them kind of
rule in or out what's the quickest path
with path you know because they may also
have an existing mental health condition
they may also be on prescription
medication and so part of the
conversation may be uh what what path is
the quickest path to get connected with
an additional resource who who are you
considering reaching out to a PCP would
probably be in that equation where
there's some other factors there um if
they didn't have insurance we would be
reaching out to providers that we know
either uh work on a sliding scale or
they have a area of specialty with with
First Responders or firefighters and so
they're open to working with folks uh
either at a reduced rate or or you know
uh SL scale um if they didn't have
insurance and that was something that
they would likely need to navigate this
process we'd be helping them connect
with medicate or going through the
application process to kind of navigate
that as well so it would never be us
kind of meeting and then just kind of
moving on we we try to support through
that whole process anticipate where the
challenges would be connecting them with
resources that would help them navigate
the process and then the
followup Zam
Sullivan thank you Mr Mr chairman thank
you for taking the question um you
testified that $150,000 would be
insufficient to uh cover the cost of
this um do you have an idea of what a
sufficient amount would
be the uh fiscal I'm not sure if the
fiscal note sheet we submitted the
16th I don't see
it me
see
okay we we anticipated based on the
numbers that we had in trying to
estimate the impact in our capacity uh
we we estimated having to hire a new uh
field rep position a full-time position
um and I have the numbers here let me
just see if I can tease them out I'm
sorry
thank you
John so for fiscal
year 2026 it would be
111,000 and that's I'm sorry and that's
over and above the cost of the actual
program that that cost is not factoring
in the
$150,000 that was initially reference
this is just the cost to be able to hire
a new full-time position and absorb the
capacity that may come in through that
volume of potential clients for followup
for followup just just to make sure
we're clear it looks like
$260,000 would be sufficient to fund
I mean when I look at the the fiscal
note here it's it's 106 for the 26 and
111 so two I I believe the initial
proposal said 150 so 250 would but I
think the estimates are 106 and 111 so
217 over the the two the
bium thank you
all represent Granger thank you Mr chair
so the governor has implemented hiring
freeze do you expect that by the time
this is passed the employee we it would
be justifiable to hire an employee for
this while we're possibly letting go of
employers for other stuff employees for
other
stuff I'm not sure how to respond to
that other than um to say that when
we're looking at a candidate for this
type of position the you know the
background and experience that somebody
would need to be able to come into the
world the roles that we're in and
respond to somebody who is dealing with
trauma and have had significant events
um I don't know that all positions would
translate to that position in terms of
kind of the the role of a a potentially
vacant position and a position opening
um other than to say you know we would
have our normal job posting and and and
process interview process if that was
available to us if we weren't able to do
that we would wouldn't be able to do
that thank
you can me just read back what I think I
hearde is that there's currently five
departments that qualify under this five
person five known departments with
several departments that had not
responded yes there are we're hiring
someone then to administer a program for
five small town departments no that that
um I apologize I have a lot of documents
here all right I believe this was also
referenced oh the fiscal note hadn't
but currently four based on the
information that was available to us in
this Recruitment and Retention report
that
uh of 2022 was there are
4,281 individuals who be eligible for
EAP Services through the proposal
there's a those are the volunteer
firefighters there are there
are also departments with five or less
full-time firefighters would be
eligible what we know about departments
2024 uh fire departments are required to
submit information about how many
employees they have how many full-time
firefighters they have uh only
72% submitted that information of that
72% there were only five additional fire
departments that were named as having
five or less uh firefighters so there's
an additional 28% and you know what are
those are those the majority are those
in rural areas there's pieces of that
that we can't really tease out for
certain but what we do know is that
4,000 281 plus I would say plus whatever
those departments are plus whatever
those departments okay now I understand
thank you any other
questions thank you Mr chairman thank
you for the questions um this says First
Responders and then it sets the limit at
five full-time paid First Responders
yes does that include fire police gpw
that that are technically First
Responders and are we should we expect
more than 4,000 that would take part in
this I'm not sure how to respond to that
it may I mean I based on the information
4,256 on call or volunteer members of
state so I think that would cover that
group but I'm not sure that that
language that I just referenced is taken
directly out of this report so as of
July 2022 there were 4,2 56 on call or
volunteer members of fire
department I guess it doesn't it doesn't
specify if that's also emergency
services to your
point I'm getting for followup I'm
getting nods of yet affirmative behind
you and we don't know from the actual
department so um that would be a
question because that would uh
exponentially increase the process for
additional workman's compensation claims
across three different SE ments of
public
employment I don't know if I should I
representative Cel can you respond to
that yeah so the goal of this is not to
increase workers comp the goal is to get
people who are working First Responders
to be able to access immediate care so
that they don't get to the point of
needing workers comp right because if if
by having two or three consultations
with someone in an EAP program allows
them to work through or identify
strategies to avoid getting further
through the process they're never going
to get to the point of needing the
workers comp the goal is to to create
level good I welome okay thank
you representative L thank you Mr chair
quickly to that point when you get hurt
on a job you within 24 hours you need to
file for workman's C immediately so
would that now go away with this
plan uh I don't believe that that would
go away at all but again there's a
a mental illness caused by trauma is
because of repeated trauma we know that
over the course of a career um someone
who works as a first responder and
there's there are other people who are
going to be better at testifying to this
than I am but may see over 2,000
individual incidents and that cumulative
effect is what ultimately leads them to
the the various issues or followup sorry
I just want to make sure one's not
replacing the other that's all no the
goal is not to replace it's it's really
to provide an additional layer to
support especially our volunteers and
those from really small communities and
in like one of the examples about fire
departments one of the Departments close
to where I live has one uh fire chief
that's a paid person for the town and
the entire rest of the department is all
volunteer call Firefighters we have
another community near us that has one
police officer for their town right when
that police officer is off duty I guess
they get to get off duty at some Point
um you know they're covered through
mutual Aid right but what we're hearing
over and over is just that the it's so
hard to access any kind of care and that
these people need a lifeline and so I
really designed this bill to be the
lifeline and you'll see it's not a
partisan Bill I just want to be really
clear um one of the people who's here to
testify is representative Mark PR he's a
much better expert around the area of
First Responders that I am and we'll
probably be able to answer a lot of
those questions I this is not my
professional back ground it just came
from a place of hearing these stories
and these pleas for support and thinking
what can we do as legislators to give
them the lifeline okay thank you
representative Granger thank you Mr
chair and thanks for taking my question
so my understanding is that this bill
would require the hiring of a new
employee um however and with fairness to
the bill sponsors they couldn't have
known that this executive order came out
when Bill filing season was here and I I
believe they have the best of in with
this bill however I have here the
executive order from the governor is
whereas the state is facing a budget get
into the good parts not reading the
whole thing whereas the state is facing
a budget deficit necess necessitating a
recalibration of spending levels
consistent with fiscal responsibility as
and whereas the governor of New
Hampshire is positioned to review all
state payroll expenditures as well as to
balance and protect the interest of the
New Hampshire citizens of New Hampshire
skipping a bit all full-time and
part-time classified and classified
employee positions within the agencies
of the executive branch that are vacant
on the effective date of this order or
that become vacant after the effective
date of this order shall remain vacant
unless otherwise explicitly Exempted by
this order etc etc so this now it
doesn't explicitly say no hiring of new
employees but doesn't that seem to us
that this is there's unfortunately no
legs to this legislation with this
governor
I'm not sure if that's a question
directly for me or for the group yeah
fair enough okay that's a good question
um what's that yeah I think it it could
be a fiscal committee question in terms
of how do you again we're saying is this
the right thing to do the fiscal
committee is saying can we do
it based on the governor's guidance so
fair enough represent McKenzie
uh thank you Mr
chair let me let me see if I I can ask
this question in a
way um that you could respond so you um
you have taken a look at kind of the
landscape of of firefighters and small
communities as has the sponsor so if we
do
nothing uh in your professional opinion
is somebody who has represented these
people uh now I was a Manchester
firefighter we had access to all kinds
of services and even with that we had
some real tragedies within the
Manchester fire department so if if we
don't do something here for people who
face um the same critical kinds of uh
stresses as we do did professional
full-time firefighters what what's a
consequence uh of that to uh to our
communities uh to those IFI
as as a profession maybe you could apply
on first I appreciate the question you
know my background is I'm a licensed
social worker and I'm also a licensed
drug and alcohol
counselor uh certainly see uh the value
of trauma informed work in these areas
of not only individuals who just need
supports and resources but uh you know a
heightened level for folks who have
exposure to trauma and multiple traumas
in their in their journey I mean one of
the things that is uh often thrown out
and floated out there is that we all
have our own individual sense of
resiliency you know but um I I would say
that resiliency is something that uh
gets built on and developed
collaboratively and not just
individually you know and so I think
that folks and and you know there's
something to be said and the research
supports this around people who are
exposed to tra uh trauma getting support
and resources is uh earlier in that
process not everybody is going to have
the same impact or Consequences from a
traumatic event or exposure to a
traumatic event uh but there's can
certainly be a cumulative quality to
that and so uh I'm I'm very much in
favor of people having access to
supports and resources to navigate
challenges that could not only show up
and impact their uh their longevity from
that physiological standpoint but
quality of life family relationships uh
you know there the the rip effect of
these kinds of experiences can be
far-reaching
okay um for another Germain question
thank you Mr chair is this something
government I think that working uh
creatively and collaboratively for
providing resources can happen a lot of
different ways I I I would say with a
group as large as this is it's going to
create it's going to require some
creativity and some intentionality uh
but I think that there are other places
to access resources um what that plan
might look like I think would you know
take some folks to sit down and try to
Hash it out and see if it's possible I
think that our group our state of New
Hampshire EAP the work we do with all
state employees and their family members
to include people who have exposure to
imense trauma we're a um we're a
resource that does really uh complex
work
and at a fairly low
cost thank
you okay uh representative aval thank
you Mr chairman so as of right now the
state assistance EAP program only
handles state employees and their family
members and their family members so this
would be follow up please this would be
an additional task for your crew it
would be and that's that's the real
justification around needing an
additional position follow last one yes
um any other state agency states around
us that do the same thing for state
employees and then public
employees I'm not aware of them but I
haven't looked so I I apologize I don't
have more information to respond to that
thank you thank you Mr
chairman all right good and
representative
Solan actually I'm not sure who this
question is for but it appears that
there is a fiscal note that the
committee does not have are we going to
be receiving
this we we will
uh Davis Mr Allen can you make sure that
we get the fiscal note that I parently
has been written but we haven't received
can you get a hold of that and send it
to the committee by the end of the day
if we haven't gotten it I understand but
I believe it exists so if you can get
that I appreciate it thank you thank
you okay um thank you Ser for your
testimony I appreciate it and uh if we
good morning Mr chairman and the rest of
the committee my name is Mark PR I
represent Hillsboro 15 which is
Manchester Ward 8 a little bit about me
I did 30 years in the city of nashor As
A Firefighter retired as Lieutenant I'm
now a deputy chief in the town of
eping the other reason that I'm here is
that I run the gr estate critical
incident stress management team I've
been doing that for almost 40 years so
the grand estate critical inance stress
team we respond to departments police
Fire EMS dispatchers that have had a
critical incident we try to educate them
about what's going to happen to them uh
and if it does happen to them to try and
get back to us so we can refer so this
program that is being proposed would
that because if I can't do it and they
may not want to come back to me and seek
the more autonomous or
Anonymous connection with the
EAP right um so we're looking to refer
and we can refer them to the EAP and if
they have some on staff who's been
trained to deal with emergency
responders because we are a little bit
different than most people right and we
look at things differently we react to
things differently
So and I've been told that we scare the
crap out of some mental health
professionals when we tell our stories
so they really need to know who we are
what we're about and what they're going
to hear
right so we talked about the freeze is
this position really important
I truly believe it is
because in my experience in the state
over the last 40 years I've watched
suicide of First
Responders climb through the roof it's
almost like we're in a race with the
veterans to see who can end up on top of
that pile unfortunately right so without
this kind of help for
them it's just going to get worse right
or if they just leave the service right
because I can't take this anymore we
talked
about retention and
recruitment but the other thing that
walks out of that door if they leave or
if they pass on is their
experience right you look at fire
service when I started in
1980 we had a lot of
fires we got a lot of experience so as a
young guy coming through the door I got
led by seasoned officers and other
firefighters that showed me the ropes
and we had plenty of opportunity to do
that we don't get that anymore fire
prevention is working
right I can't tell you the last time I
went to a fire and upping I go Mutual
Aid thank goodness right so we can keep
our skills
up but those guys that walk out with all
that experience early before we're ready
to replace them
is killing the Departments right
um into your question a lot of times
when we have a bad incident we everybody
on that incident fill out that first
Contact form for um workers comp whether
it gets used or not I I've also sat on
the uh PTSD commission and we've been
working with workers comp and they're
looking at
24 hours from when your reactions or
signs start not and sure sometimes you
can go back to oh it was this call but
sometimes it's just a collection of call
after call after call that affects them
right and the thing about critical
instant stress is what affects me may
not affect anyone else and what affects
everyone else may not affect me because
we all have personal baggage that we
accumulate as we go through life and
something insignificant as a shoe in the
middle of the
road wipes you out because it reminds
you of your kids shoe or something like
that who knows right so early
intervention just my program alone I
think helps quite a bit me being able to
refer them to EAP with a trained
professional may
only take a couple of conversations to
get them back on track because when
we're in the very beginning of this
we're not mentally ill people we're just
someone who got our feet knocked out
from underneath us and need coaching to
get back on track and sometimes that's
all it is sometimes it's more than that
but if we can intervene very early catch
it before it becomes PTSD and it's just
critical incident of stress we're ahead
of the game we're saving money right so
hiring freeze is this position worth it
to save lives
absolutely and if it doesn't get
implemented until the freeze comes off
at least it'll be in place ready for
when the governor says okay we can start
hiring again we're back we're back in
the black right so I think we need to
move this forward
uh and see where it goes and with that
I'll take questions all right any
questions representative Warden and then
representa thanks for taking our
question
representative when somebody is a new
hire as a first responder I assume
there's some sort of physical fitness
test is there a psych eval or mental
fitness test that's given to these
people before they're hired so yes they
you get a medical test uh you go through
a physical um not sure how much on the
on the
uh mental health side I think there's
some it's been a long time since I've
been hired so I know definitely in the
police there's a mental health
evaluation uh the other piece of that is
my training gets out to pretty much
every firefighter in the state every EMT
in the state and I know on the police
side they get it as well so they're made
aware of critical incident stress
uh what it looks like how to try to
mitigate it on your own and and how to
reach out when you can't follow that's
ongoing training you provide not just in
reaction to an incident but you give
that training to different departments
andol okay that's great thanks and
represent
stop thank you Mr chairman um we talked
a lot about firefighters and EMTs in in
particular about fires but um what other
kinds of trauma inducing incidents do
firefighters and EMTs and U volunteers
so we do probably
75% or more
EMS and the rest is now fir so it used
to be the other way around so we go to
all kinds of medical emergencies motor
vehicle accidents that are still pretty
horrific you've heard about I95 lately
right and how horrific those are
um the things I've seen over the
years is incredible right plus you're
going to Baby calls that don't always
make it you're going to domestic
violence right not only just the police
side but we get to pick up the victims
who got the crap beat out of them and
you can't even recognize their face
because they're so blatant and I'm going
to tell you in the small town it's
probably worse I worked in the city of
nashar I never lived there the only
people I knew in the city of nashar were
fellow firefighters right so I could put
up a pretty good wall because I didn't
know
them you go to the small town you either
know them or you're related to
them right
so the worst thing I think
is going to do CPR on your mom because
you're the closest one there and you're
waiting for the rest of the crew to come
so you can stop doing it and get out of
the room but nope I'm there right um I I
incident this firefighter went to the
crash was working on the guy he got
ejected from the car and he's working
and he looks up and he sees the license
plate and
brother he had no idea because his brain
just said don't recognize that you you
need you need to work don't recognize it
and as soon as he saw the plate he goes
out so those are the things that are
happening out there
um drunk drivers are up there they're
killing people left and right drunk
drivers don't drive
slow okay represent
McKenzie I'll ask a just a quick
question you're out of nashal I used to
be yeah I come out of Manchester so when
we go back to the firehouses five six
seven eight 10 people there if you go to
a little town like your town now that
you're a deputy chief of or a number of
communities uh have one firefighter on
duty or none so they
dispersed there's a difference correct
when you look at that support system oh
absolutely
um it used to be funny because back in
the day there was a lot of stigma to
this it's falling off quite a bit but it
would be funny we'd come back from a bad
call we'd all be sitting around the
table drinking a cup of
coffee I would be debriefing them and
they had no idea what I was
doing right yeah don't give me any of
that stuff that you do I'm all set with
that okay right but if if and like he
said in the small
town you pack up and you go home you bu
Yourself by yourself and I'm going to
tell you one of the
biggest Rising population of of suicide
is
retirees right I look at my life in in
nashar I spent onethird of my life or
more
more with a
family that maybe I like better than my
other family right because when I had a
bad day A bad call I could talk to them
experienced I walked out I retired from
NASA got up in the morning I was no
longer Lieutenant PR I was Mark
Pro I no longer had those friends I
now I have nobody that I can reach out
on on a weekly basis daily basis I still
keep in contact with some of them but
those years that I wasn't in the fire
service it's pretty hard and and luckily
I do this so I knew and when I was
having trouble I could reach out to
people in my circle to
get what I needed not everybody is that
lucky especially in a small department
they have nobody to reach out to and
sometimes in that smaller Department the
stigma is still there so sorry okay
trying to be short but no no thanks so
let's um i' thank you so much any last
okay if we can have uh represent
Damon okay thank you sir I appreciate
issue
SEC thank you um and good afternoon Mr
chair and committee members I'm state
representative H Damon I serve half of
Sullivan County aworth langon lemster
Goan Washington Springfield sunap my
hometown of Cen and the City of
Claremont um and Brian Sullivan has been
telling me for the last two and a half
years that this is the best committee so
I just need to acknowledge that I've
never spoken before
you so I am in fact here in support of
this bill of those nine towns that I
represent eight of them either have
entirely volunteer first responder
services or less than five one only one
has uh full paid
staff I think we're all very grateful to
the many First Responders who put their
lives on the line for our communities
the toll on their well-being can be
substantial and the more times that a
person is exposed to trauma the greater
the likelihood that they develop
PTSD the studies that I looked at show a
10 to 35% incidence of PTSD I think I
just lost power okay I'm just going to
tell you what it says um 10 to 35%
incidents of PTSD in First
Responders listening to representative
PLS remarks I was reminded of a loss in
cipe within the last four or 5
years a young woman 22 years old coming
home from her first post colle job in a
really freaky year in the wrong place at
the wrong time accident a tree fell down
on her car her moving car and she died
on the spot and the first first
responder when it was called in by a
vehicle behind her was her lifetime best
friend
her dad's the principal of the high
school in centi to this day I cannot
imagine being that young woman coming on
the scene of her best
friend and having to deal with that we
know that when you treat
PTSD um when you initiate treatment
early it's much more successful and so
the remarks that I was hearing about the
concerns of
increasing likelihood of workman's
compensation claims it's actually the
the opposite of that if you look up the
data for EAP programs they decrease
workman's comp costs not
increase
um and now I'm having a brain cramp and
you know the power cord is down in
education funding um I will just say
that I very vigorously support this bill
I think it is critically important that
we keep adequate Staffing throughout our
districts for First Responders and that
reminds me of the remaining piece in
convers
with several Fire Chiefs in my district
in particular with the Springfield Fire
Chief who is very experienced he notes
the difficulty of retaining people when
the level of stress leads to unhealthy
behaviors and relationship struggles
because they're not addressing the
trauma and the stress in a timely and
effective way this could really help
retain people who want to stay on the
force but need to be well so thank thank
you for your time thank you for your
work thank you appreciate it any
comments uh questions
rather okay yes M Schultz thank you Mr
chair I just if you have the opportunity
to send us uh what you weren't able to
because it sounds uh helpful yes thank
you for the prompt we'll do take care
all right uh seeing no more questions
and having no more pin cards um this
586 and we will recess for 20 minutes
it's tight um do you want to give
another 10 we we recess for 30
minutes and I be back in the seats at uh
1:10 and we'll pick up testimony from
can
e
all right welcome back everyone and I
appreciate your
patience um I'm opening the hearing on
House Bill 299 FN seeing that we have a
quorum it's an act relative to the
reward of attorney's fees and costs in
workers compensation claims and
representative uh Pearson are you
introducing this bill please we'd like
you thank you Mr chairman thank you for
the opportunity to sit in the big seat
rooms my name is Representative Steve
Pearson Rockingham District 13 which
encompasses Dairy
and what I bring before you today is
299 the premise of 299 involves workers
compensation and
the responsibility financial
responsibility when it comes to a
positive litigation
outcome so one of the things that I do
for the legislature is I also I'm the
vice chair of the PTSD commission I have
been for or a couple of terms now and
one of the things that we've learned um
sadly is in workers compensation
events there's a couple things that
occur the first one being everybody gets
that Dreadful denial letter within the
first 30 days as a procedural move um
partially due to the limitations that
the law puts on insurance companies to
make contact with
someone who filed the workers's
compensation claim um but the other
thing is is that
when you're perceived to be AG grieved
right if you are injured or or worse if
you know dismembered or anything on the
job and you go through the workers's
compensation process a lot of times you
have to fight for your
right to that
claim the battle that which occurs there
is is extraordinarily one-sided as you
would imagine right so you
have a worker who's already hurt who now
has to engage in a legal action against
either a corporation or municipality or
or an entity such as that so what this
says is that you would be entitled to
reimbursement of those
costs now I have before you that I
believe was passed out the an amendment
to this
the amendment adds three or excuse me
four words to the bill um it was done so
at the request of the
methodology of the bill on the
methodology near the bottom it says the
department notes the language does not
specify whom is responsible for
reimbursement reasonable Council fees
and
costs taking a note of that we clean
that
up so I I'm I believe the method ology
was done by the Department of Labor so
who as to who is responsible that that
is the impetus of the amendment and why
it was was brought forward at that
request so getting again getting back to
the the substance of of why this why
this exists you know
specifically with the experiences we had
on the PTSD commission and just the the
amazing battle that people have to go
through for
something that can be extraordinarily
financially taxing right and there's a
lot of people that just frankly give up
because they don't have the means or
they're not willing to risk the means to
fight for what they believe is right so
that is where this comes from
and um we we're fortunate to have a a
well-respected um workers comp attorney
with us today who also sits on the PTSD
commission that I'm sure will be able to
answer technical aspects of this that I
certainly
cannot okay thank you thank you for
introducing this bill are there any
committee saying none thank you sir I
appreciate
good afternoon Mr chair honorable
members of the committee for the record
my name is Brian will um still the
president of the professional
firefighters of New Hampshire uh thank
you for allowing me uh once again the
opportunity to speak to you this morning
in or this afternoon in favor of House
Bill
299 um I represent approximately 2,000
active and retired firefighters across
the state of New Hampshire uh which is
an inherently dangerous profession as we
are all aware uh and I believe that our
states our cities and our towns have an
obligation to protect those uh that
provide this very um dangerous public
service what we find in the fire service
is um claims are often workers comp
claims are often routinely denied um
thanks to the explanation that
representative Pearson provided um a lot
of the reason for this some in some
cases is to satisfy a um part of the law
which requires there needs to be a
response or a claim paid within 21 days
of
filing in many cases what this does with
our members is they see their claims
routinely denied um because quite
frankly there is no reason to not do so
um from an insurance company's
standpoint there is no obligation to pay
a claim at the first level and quite
Frank frankly we see more and more of
our claims becoming routinely denied um
because there is no downside um if if
you're the one that's paying out the
claim so our members then in order to
further fight this need to file a uh for
a first level Hearing in order to get a
ruling from the Department as to whether
or not their claim would be approved um
in many cases we're finding that our
members choose not to do so because of
the financial burden there are
experiencing by being out with a
work-related injury uh and they're only
uh they're only potentially either
receiving um whatever savings they have
um or getting paid from their earned
time or their disability leave they
don't have the funds to then go um get
legal counsel to fight this claim so in
many cases they're not doing so adding
to U what is already a traumatic
situation for them in the
moment should they get denied uh upon a
department level hearing and they appeal
this and they win on the appeal their
claims are then covered the attorney's
fees can then be covered um by the
insurance carrier but it is not until
such time that they were to appeal the
Department's uh ruling and be successful
that those claims would be denied all
this bill does is it bumps up the uh
compensation for those attorney fees by
one step um so it's already in existence
we're just trying to bump it up by one
step in hopes that this will um avoid
future frivolous denials um for our
members so it's just a um in practice
we're just trying to protect our members
allow them the opportunity to um to have
full representation when they file a
claim for an occupational related injury
or illness U with that I would uh
entertain any questions that I might be
able to
answer may not be many but represent
labr
thank you Mr chair most likely I have
this wrong so humor me let's just walk
through it together as an example I have
a guy that gets hurt on the
job uh he's out of work he files his
claim maybe it's a $1,000
claim it gets rejected goes to to do
gets rejected then he appeals
it after battling back and forth with
them they approve
it you said the insurance
carrier my insurance carrier
pays the freight on that so the the
workers comp insurance carrier that
initially denied the claim which would
be mine yeah would then if they denied
my claim or your claim in this instance
is the injured employee um yes they
would be the ones responsible for those
attorneys fees at that level to my
knowledge and if attorney oconor knows
differently than I'm going to let the
conversation develop a little bit I have
some more questions but let's let it
oil yeah thanks any other questions
representative
Sullivan oops you uh mentioned that the
um um if the department uh denies the
claim and it gets appealed that the
attorney's fees for those that appeal
would be covered under current law um
who pays for that those attorney fees is
that the insurance company I believe
currently is the insurance company yeah
and so this simply means that if the uh
insurance company denies the claim and
you go to the department the department
uh approves the claim those um any
attorney fees at the department would
also be covered by the um the insurance
company for the employees uh attorneys
fees not for anything that the that the
you Subs good
questions saying non thank you thank you
testimony I'd like to call George russos
please
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee my name is George russos R O U
SS o I'm a lawyer with or Reno and
conquered and I'm here afternoon on
behalf of two uh Insurance
clients uh one is the American uh
property Casualty Insurance Association
I've just handed out their written
testimony and I won't repeat what they
have to say uh our second client is uh
the uh New Hampshire Association of
domestic insurance companies and um
together uh these clients
represent uh most of the workers comp
insurance that is written in in our
state we oppose this
bill I don't think that the uh
proponents of the bill uh give enough
credit to the hearing officers at the
insurance department and I mean at the
uh labor department and and the job that
they do these are skilled experienced uh
people who hear these cases day in and
day out
and they look favorably upon I think
it's there's General agreement within
the uh workers comp community that their
decisions are fair uh and balanced
there's going to be uh a view on the
part of one side or the other that that
uh uh decisions are not always correct
but they do they do a very good job and
they have in my view for many many years
at determining whether the injury that
is work rated number one and whether
it's disabling those those are the
questions before the hearing
officers this system was designed to
make it unnecessary to have legal
council represent either party um
and it's designed to be an informal
process and an exped expedited uh
process uh The Rules of Evidence don't
apply so there are medical reports that
are introduced into evidence and these
adjudications generally uh resolve
matters I think the labor department
would have statistics uh more current
than anything I have but I think that
there are is a sort of an equal uh
division between successful uh workers
comp claims and and those that are not
and then as has been
mentioned uh
if uh if there's an appeal by either
party that appeal is taken to the
workers compensation appeals board that
board has three members uh it's chaired
by an attorney that's a member of the
appeals panel uh and then there's a
representative of Labor and a
representative of employers and those
three hear the appeals and if the
claimant is
successful uh the attorney's fees and
costs of that appeal are paid for by the
employer or the insurance company but
ultimately the employer pays what
whatever costs we're talking about are
born by the employer who pays the
workers compensation premium so we think
the current system uh works
well uh and that uh the interjection of
encouraging lawyers to participate at
the hearings level uh would not be
beneficial to the public or to Employers
in this state thank you Mr chairman
okay thank you for your testimony do we
have any questions representative kale
thank you Mr chair and thank you Mr
russos just to be clear when you say the
cost is born uh by in the premiums those
are spread out across everyone buying
Insurance in in this market is there a
higher uh is there like a a score you
keep of how many the particular employer
racks up does that does that affect
their uh premiums I would expect it
might premium sor based represent kahill
on primarily on the classification of
the workers of the of the employer uh
but also upon the uh work the loss
experience of each particular employer
so uh that would affect the uh
ratemaking process for employers if
their losses were greater than those
those of somebody else and then there is
a risk pool that residual Market that uh
would apply fortunately things are very
healthy right now as you know in the
workers compensation market and they
have been for many years
but to me it wasn't all that long ago
maybe seems so to many of you but back
in the 90s some of you may remember
workers compensation was just not
available at all to employers and the
market was approaching
50% where no no insurance company wanted
to write workers compensation and so
that led to reforms
uh in the workers compensation law and
it's been a tremendous uh success over
the years in fact rates have declined uh
over I think over the past at least 10
years annually so it's a healthy system
right now follow up yes for followup
thank you sir would you attribute that
those those premium declines the rates
to improve safety practice I would yes
sir thank you sir yes okay repres solvin
thank you for taking my question um the
um you you indicated that about 50% of
the time uh the the appeal at the uh
hearing level hearing officer level um
is in favor of the um uh the
worker um which arguably means that 50%
of the time the insurance company got it
wrong um in which case
wouldn't it be fair for the uh uh the
worker to be uh compensated for their um
legal fees in instances where the
insurance company got it
wrong no I think the current system is
fair and by the way don't hold me to
that 50% I think uh I would defer the
labor department to assign whatever
statistics they have I just I just took
that number out of some data then did
you make up anything else no I and I
didn't make that up either but but I I
could stand corrected uh but no I think
the system is fair we don't need to G it
up with lawyers at the hearing uh level
process we've got hearing officers that
can tell and ascertain whether which
side is correct whether the the injuries
work rated and whether it's disabled
without without encouraging the
participation of of lawyers
unnecessarily so so I I agree with that
statement but the question I've got is
of these cases that are heard by the
insurance panel that you talked about
how many of those
employes have lawyers with them present
at
that at that hearing I think that's a
great question I I don't know the answer
to the question but hopefully the the
labor department can can give you that
answer that's that's a good question I
don't know any
my question is um you're talking about
prosay claimants you're saying that
people
can um Can represent themselves and the
just the uh system allows for that but
in light of that um would you admit that
it can get very complicated a workers
compensation case can even at the uh
even at the hearing level let alone the
appeals board and would would you agree
that you have to follow certain
guidelines and rules and timing of uh
when you file and how you file and that
for an injured worker do you think that
that a burden that Injured Workers may
want to shift off to a professional uh
uh an attorney to help them with their
process well thank you thank you for the
question and certainly that's an option
that uh that a claimant has is to is to
hire a lawyer no one's no one's saying
they don't they can't hire a lawyer but
I I think and you would know this that
these hearing
officers understand that people are
injured workers are there unrepresented
and they make allowances in my
experience for uh for that fact and that
they may not be familiar with the the
system I remember having a
hearing with a hearing officer and
representing a claim it years ago and uh
my U the
claimant explain the circumstances of
his injury and his treat and why he's
disabled and we went into that and then
the hearing
officer who I really appreciate said now
we have to hear from the insurance
company
so that happened it's an it's maybe not
the usual practice but I I do think the
that these hearing officers deserve a
lot of credit they they understand that
people Injured Workers are there and
they're not represented and they're not
as familiar with the processes as they
might be and they make allowances for
that and try to result uh try to uh give
the come to the right decision and the
fair decision and I think they do by and
large and then as you say if that
doesn't work uh and there's an appeal
and the appeal is successful those
attorneys fees and costs are paid paid
employer represent
Sol um at the hearing level um does the
insurance company send a an
inexperienced lay person or an attorney
to represent the insurance company again
that that I think is a good question
about representation on the on the other
side and of course you're talking about
uh self-insured uh groups as well that
don't have insurance companies they they
insure themselves and and uh uh when I
last was uh doing this work the uh
typically there would be an insurance uh
Adjusters so he would have experience in
workers compensation for sure but uh as
often as not they would not be lawyers
whether there and sometimes there would
be lawyers that would represent the uh
employer um again it might be helpful to
to hear from the insurance department I
mean the uh the labor department uh
about about that uh distribution of on
the other
side Zam K thank you again Mr Russ just
to be clear it I believe I heard you as
an attorney saying that we don't need
attorneys gumming up the
works is that correct thank you I I I I
think that this is another topic bigger
topic than this bill but I think we we
we have just too many lawyers involved
in too many things today and as a lawyer
I say that and don't tell my partner as
I said it but uh it it's just it's
gotten so comp you can't read a
newspaper without uh being a lawyer to
understand what so I think we've gone
too far but that is that's a that's a
topic for another day uh I'm happy to
happy to talk about thank you sir yeah
thank you all right
sir thank you for your testimony I
appreciate it thank you I'd like to call
please good afternoon Mr chairman
members of the committee um so my name
is Jared Connor I'm with the firm of
Shaheen and Gordon um my role in this
and I support this legislation I am a
claimants attorney in workers
compensation it's all I do it's all I've
done for about 20 years now is represent
Injured Workers um I am also the
attorney representative on the PTSD
commission and have been for five years
um that rep representative Pearson
mentioned um so I'm really here to
answer some questions if any about the
way that all of this works but I do want
to at least Begin by noting that I don't
know that it's entirely accurate to say
that these first level hearings are sort
of intended to and actually operate with
no attorneys and we don't want attorneys
guming up the works the two main things
I want to say about that is that first
to my knowledge virtually every time
there is a hearing a first level hearing
at the labor department the insurance
carrier or the self-insured through its
third party administrator has an
attorney there representing them so a
prosay injured worker who goes up there
by themselves is facing an attorney on
the other side so there's already an
attorney in the works whether adding
another one is going to gum up the works
um I think the best evidence that that's
not true is that when a prosay litigant
asks for a hearing at the labor
department and the labor department can
confirm this they will routinely
schedule it for at least an hour and a
half if there are attorneys on both
sides they schedule it for an hour
having two attorneys does not gum up the
works it Smooths things out and makes
things more efficient because the
attorneys who do this work understand
the cases we know how to present them
they go much smoother and faster than
dealing with an individual who doesn't
know what they're doing or how to
present the
case to that point I think the the
Practical issue that this is intended to
address is that when you're an injured
worker and your claim has been
immediately denied you need to request a
hearing at the labor department so that
you can try to get some benefits coming
in you know you've just had this
catastrophic injury your bills aren't
being paid the medical is not being
covered you need relief fast and the
labor department is set up for that so
you can request a hearing and you'll be
up there within two months maybe three
at the max to have your hearing and
present your
case if you have a hearing like that and
Prevail what you get from the labor
department is an order that benefits are
payable meaning you get retroactive pay
back to the beginning of when you first
went out of work so maybe you get 3 to
four months worth of retroactive pay
that currently is how attorneys are paid
if we represent people at the first
level so you go to the hearing you're
successful maybe 3 to four months of
retroactive pay 20% of that comes to
attorneys the Practical issue is that
for a lot of Injured Workers that
four-month window of pay it might be
6,000 8,000 bucks maybe less 20% of that
isn't enough to justify hiring an
attorney um and so they find it
difficult to get representation at that
first level that's really I think the
Practical issue um it is certainly true
that then on appeal the way that the
fees are currently structured is that if
you proceed and Prevail at the appeals
level then attorney's fees are awardable
and payable by the insurance carrier if
we go to a hearing and lose then
attorneys are simply not paid and that's
the way it works it's a contingent
Arrangement um and that's set up by the
statute this is the same exact thing
except at the first level hearings so
the idea would be to allow people to
retain experienced Council so that they
can present their case and have a better
shot of prevailing whether that's the
initial denial when they really need to
be able to Marshal evidence and it's you
know it's true that these first level
hearings are pretty informal there again
there are no rules of evidence um that
being said the legal issues in workers
comp can be fairly complex and they've
just become more so in the last 15 to 20
years I would say you know we've
introduced presumptions in the law the
Supreme Court has weighed in on a number
of occasions making the cases more
complicated as to whether you have an
injury that arises from what they call a
neutral risk or a direct risk or a mixed
risk these are legal categories that can
affect whether you qualify your average
pro litigant is not going to understand
or know about the appeal of margison
case and how to argue it which is more
likely to lead to a unfavorable decision
so those are the kinds of situations
where it can absolutely help to have
experienced Council come in early to
assist them with their claim if we under
this regime if we were to go to that
first appeal and lose again no fee is
payable um so that's that's one
circumstance probably the primary
circumstance where this would assist
people in getting competent experienced
representation at their first level
hearing the other is another situation
that I see not at all uncommonly where
people people haven't accepted workers
comp claim the insurance company is
paying for everything they're supposed
to pay for they're getting their weekly
benefits maybe they've gone through
surgery they've been disabled for a
while um at that point at any point in
the case but usually at that point the
insurance carrier can request a hearing
to seek to reduce or terminate benefits
on the theory that this person could or
should be working and maybe they haven't
been given a Work Release by their
doctor so there's a dispute about
whether they can work the insurance
carrier can request a hearing to review
that if you go to that hearing and
Prevail by showing no my doctors all
agree I'm still disabled and can't be
working right now then what's awarded to
you is nothing it's just continued
status quo so there is no retroactive
benefit out of which to award attorney's
fees so again people have a difficult
time finding council to represent them
for these hearings where even if you do
a lot of work there is no pay involved
and this these hearings can can be a lot
of work you know when you have these
kinds of disputes about whether someone
is disabled the insurance carrier with
the assistance of their counil we'll
bring in medical experts we'll bring in
vocational experts and labor market
surveys to show what is available out in
the marketplace for these people to be
able to find work the average proa
litigant has no idea how to rebut that
how to go out and find their own expert
or pay for their own expert to be able
to challenge it adequately at the first
level so I I guess that's all I I'll
stop pontificating and answer questions
if you have that's great um any
questions please representative Hall
thank you Mr chair uh attorney oconor as
a subject matter expert in this
um does is it your opinion that this
bill would remove the 20% cap I don't
see anything specified other than
reasonable attorney fees no the 20% cap
is set by Department of Labor regulation
so that's already in the law where
attorneys fees are awarded um they are
awarded pursuant to approval by the
commissioner and that actually is in the
law you can see this um it exists
already in the law for other kind of for
this bill if a claimant prevails the
claimant shall be entitled to
reimbursement of reasonable Council fees
and costs as approved by the
commissioner meaning approval by the
labor department and that's how this
works now for existing hearings where
there is fee shifting you submit your
bill to the hearings officer who heard
the case hearing officer then reviews it
for reasonableness if they think it's
too high they can knock it down um and
then they will approve it and it's
payable by the insurance carrier thank
you representative McKenzie thank
you uh having served in the comp appeals
board I understand how
complicated uh these things can
be uh in terms of prosay
liance uh the role that the hearing
officer plays is not to present the case
correct for the prosay litigate so it's
their burden their burden to know what
the law and understand the law and
they're up against somebody who does
this every day that's certainly true um
you know the hearing officer is ideally
neutral you know they're not there to
assist the claimant um as a prosay
litigant and as a proa litigant as any
kind of claimant the burden is always on
you to present the case and to prove the
case it's always the claimants of proof
to show that this is a work rated
accident or injury um except in very
minor cases like we have some
presumption shifting um for cancer and
PTSD and First Responders but for
everything else the burden is always on
the claimant to prove the case and so it
is on them and if they don't show up
with the appropriate evidence the
hearing officer shouldn't be stepping in
to do their job for them I don't attend
Pro hearings cuz I'm not involved so
it's hard for me to generalize
for followup sir thank you uh based on
your experience when you prepare a
packet for the appeals board or or um or
the hearings
officer what is what is something like
that take in a in a complicated case to
pull out all that together so to so to
be able to present any workers comp case
essentially what you need is all of the
relevant medical records um which can be
in in most cases is Medical records that
predate the date of the injury you need
to be able to organize them
chronologically in a way that makes
sense to the hearing officer um you know
again you're therefore for a first level
hearing that takes about an hour so
these hearings move quickly and you need
to be able to present 600 Pages worth of
medical history in an organized fashion
that makes sense whether that's putting
the orthopedic notes on top in
chronological order and then saving the
PT toward the back and then being able
to present that in a way that the
hearing officer can understand and
relate to the initial
accident itself and that's leaving aside
the other issues like the labor market
surveys or other vocational evidence
that may be necessary to show uh the
difficulty the person has in finding
other
work represent K thank you Mr chair and
thank you for taking my question from
from what I've heard you say this this
afternoon it sounds like if if if an
injured employer employee comes to you
tells you the facts of what happened you
can sort of screen out the things that
are not likely to be successful and
perhaps sh the department and the employ
and the worker uh a bit of time is that
correct I mean I I certainly go through
a screening process every time a client
or potential client calls to be able to
assess it and figure out whether this is
likely to be a case that we would be
prevailing on um or whether there's some
Wrinkle in the law that actually
precludes them um that kind of thing
happens a lot is that is that answer
your question uh yes thank you thank you
very much okay represent
suvan I assume there are times when you
represent a worker who's um represented
themselves at the hearing level um is U
uh been denied by the hearing
officer um and then comes to you to see
if an appeal would be uh uh likely to be
successful and you do the
appeal is is there ever a time um when
you find that some of the things that
the work did in the
hearing
um uh is uh detrimental to the um uh to
the
appeal yeah absolutely um because they
they're not an attorney and they this is
often the first exposure these people
have ever had to the legal system and
you know they assume I'm just going to
show up at the first level and tell my
story and that'll be the end of it and
it's not quite that simple you know it
does take the proper presentation of
medical and other and so yeah it's not
at all uncommon for people who have lost
their first level hearing whether
because of a legal issue that they
didn't know how to argue or because of
medical evidence that they failed to
obtain which turned out to have been
relevant to the argument those are all
things that we know how to assess and to
present at the appeals level and usually
with some success um you know it's it's
always unfortunate when someone comes to
you after having represented themselves
and lost because it takes another four
or five months at least to get in front
of the appeals board at that point if
you Prevail great the person can be made
whole retroactively all the way back to
the beginning of their claim but they've
gone through nine to 10 maybe more
months of having no income come in from
the comp claim whatsoever so you know is
there ultimately a remedy sure but if
that kind of thing can be avoided by
getting con you know concrete adequate
representation early on I think it's to
certainly their
benefit all right again thank you sir I
appreciate your testimony okay thank you
please good afternoon my name is
Danielle Albert I'm the Deputy
Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Labor um I will try to be
brief um the department has reviewed the
language proposed by House Bill 299 we
understand uh the purpose we understand
the state of change we believe we can
implement and regulate that um just to
kind of touch on a few of the questions
that were brought up over the course of
previous testimony I understood one of
the questions to be in regard to um kind
of what's the current status of the way
fees are handled at the department level
and I think attorney o Conor in his
testimony gave a very good outline of
how that works um what I'll uh what I'll
further note is under current construct
um the current statutory construct when
an injured worker is coming into a
department level hearing um there are
sort of two ways that fees are going to
be approached if the issue in dispute
relates to the whole claim was denied so
you've got that memo of denial from the
insurance carrier uh and the injured
worker goes forward and prevails if
there is retroactive cash benefits at
issue the 20% retroactive is what is
awarded or can be awarded to the
attorney for the representation if the
claim is a compensable one meaning the
insurance carrier did not dispute that
this is a work injury but at some point
down the line Indemnity the cash
benefits are in dispute the claimant
comes in and prevails and there's a
retroactive award the attorney can be
paid through that 20% of the retroactive
award um to just as OK attorney OK Conor
had noted if there's nothing no
retroactive anything in claim it
prevails there is no mechanism by which
uh fees uh or costs can be awarded the
other mechanism is when an insurance
carrier has agreed or there is a
determination that a claim is a
compensable one so it's not an issue of
the is not a work injury it is a
compensable claim and specific medical
bills have been denied so injured worker
has been treating they've gone to see a
doctor the insurance carrier has a right
to review or does review those medical
bills and they have denied date of
service a b and c if an injured worker
comes in and prevails with their
attorney on disputed medical bills um
under current iteration of Statute fees
and costs can be awarded to the attorney
as it relates to the work done for those
medical bills um our understanding of
this proposed change is that it is now
broadening that category that uh at the
department level if an injured worker
prevails then fees and costs can be
approved by or can be paid for by the
insurance carrier we appreciate the
amendment um clarifying that that was a
question that the department had um the
other question that I um heard and I
believe it was from representative Hall
was whether or not if this change goes
into effect is that going to change the
20% um payment from retroactive Awards
um exactly as attorney Conor had
highlighted that is a provision or a
requirement that is borne out through
administrative rule at lab 207 in the
200 rules I think the department would
have to look at those administrative
rules to determine whether or not there
um needs to be a change I think the
question would be whether or not um it
would be fees and costs plus the 20% or
is the statutory language simply uh
mandating that the fees and costs is
what's awarded um and I other than that
I'm happy to take any questions if there
labry thank you Mr chair just one quick
question is there a difference in
hearing officers from level one to an
escalated level two that's uh thank you
for the question it's an excellent
question so when we are looking at the
workers's compensation system there is
there are um two tiers uh administered
through the agency for appeel the first
level appeal is done at what we call the
department level so that happens when an
insurance carrier
receives notice of a claim they've
reviewed it they issue a memo of denial
saying um we don't think this injury
arose out of it in the course of
employment um those appeals go to a
first level hearing administered through
the Department of Labor uh the
department has uh five full-time one
part-time hearing officer who adjudicate
those claims a decision renders from
that decision and any AG grieved party
can then appeal up to the next level
which is the compensation appeals board
the compensation appe heals board is an
administratively attached agency to the
Department of Labor there are 27 members
um and they comprise uh hearing is
provided presided over by a panel of the
designated members there's an attorney
member a labor member uh and an
employer's member they hear the case
they will then make a determination any
party who's grieved by that outcome then
has a right to appeal to the Supreme
Court which is outside of the the
administrative agency um so as far as a
difference between first level uh
Department level hearings and the
compensation appeals board um you know
the compensation appeals board is a
tribunal they're not Department
employees um they they are an
independent sort of agency in and of
themselves I will note that at the
department level although the hearing
officers are Department employees
they're not given Direction on how to
decide cases they are uh independent in
that regard but in those hearings it is
one adjudicator as opposed to a panel of
three you're welcome representative
McKenzie and then representative suan
um the you mentioned the medical costs
um for a long time we were not able to
get attorneys to go after Medical Only
claims and we made the change to the law
which allows them to do that now so this
is an expansion of this is actually
somewhat the same thing in the sense
that it's hard to get an attorney to to
repres pres you at the first level I I
don't know that the Department's in a
position to comment as to whether or not
it's hard to get an attorney to
represent at the first level um our
understanding of the proposed language
is that it does expand the ability uh to
have approval for the insurance carrier
to pay fees and costs to more than
simply specifically disputed medical
bills a follow-up question real quick
yes please uh prosay
claimants how do you handle pray
claimants who accumulate fees who
accumulate expenses as a result of
making a presentation before either the
uh the first in other words if they're
accumulating all the records and they're
doing all researching all of this it
doesn't speak to proos claimants at all
correct and forgive me if I
misunderstood the question um are you
asking whether or not there is a way for
prosay individuals to get reimbursement
for those costs so under this this
you're saying the attorneys
can put that in but there are people who
prosay yep who could
accumulate you know costs as a result of
making this presentation accumulating
records and all of those kinds of things
that they would have to do I understand
um as the language is drafted it is
specific relative to council fees and
costs so the department understands that
to mean the fees that are in the fees
and costs that that are incurred through
having Council so I I I we do not read
or understand it to expand to pray
individuals also having those costs
reimbursed through the insurance carrier
all right thank you thank you good
question representative Sullivan thank
you um it was asked earlier and it was
anticipated that you could answer um
what is the current uh uh representation
level for uh workers at the department
level hearings uh percentage wise or
something that's an excellent question
and forgive me I don't have exact
numbers with me today but I am happy to
see if it's something that we can
generate for you I will say uh kind of
broadly or globally speaking um a fair
number of individuals of Injured Workers
appear to be represented um either at
the outset when petitioning for a
hearing or obtain Council afterwards
there are some number that go forward
Pro say um and I'm happy to try to drill
down and see if we can get an exact uh
an exact figure for you on the insurance
or on the employer insurance carrier
side the observation has been it's
almost there's almost always an attorney
involved follow please would you say
it's the majority of um uh workers that
that I will say from
observation my my recollection is it's
it it feels as
though a little more than half but I
would prefer to perhaps get you a solid
number just so that I'm not misspeaking
or misleading thank you and Mr Allen if
you could get that information send it
out please I appreciate it
representative Hall thank you for taking
my question um if a worker appears with
a union appointed um attorney is there
any difference in compensation very good
question um no I the fees and costs
would be addressed the same way
regardless of whether or not it was uh
attorney provided through a union or an
attorney that the individual uh
hired or hired from a private
firm okay seeing no further questions
thank you again for your testimony I
appreciate
it with regard to the numbers my
apologies um that you asked after
representative Sullivan would you like
me to send them to the entire committee
or okay yes please thank you um okay
seeing no further questions having no
further uh pin cards
I uh recess the committee or or I close
299 I'm now opening the uh hearing on HB
303 relative requiring the Department of
Labor review and adopt workers
occupational safety requirements that
are similar to OSHA standards and
representative you you as the sponsor
you're going to be uh presenting
this
cool and do we have a no and do you have
a pin card if you get a chance yeah when
you get done please all right sir the
floor is
you I think I'll start start off
with I don't know why this place always
makes me lose my voice but it
does um
one piece of uh information that is
commonly not known is that
um public sector workers are not covered
by OIP um it's generally assumed that
everybody's covered by OIP um and in
some states everybody is covered by Osan
um not in New Hampshire in New Hampshire
all private sector employees are covered
by Osha Osha and their safety
standards um public sector workers are
covered by the Department of Labor in
its safety
standards
um it is undeniable that the OSHA
standards are far more
complete um than the department of labor
standards um there's never been an
argument from the Department on that
point um the um with with that I'll I'll
give you a little bit of History I I've
been at this for a while um and
um it uh goes back about five years um
in
2020 um I sponsored HB
1171 and it was designed to create a um
OSHA state plan for New
Hampshire uh the state plan is a very
involved process between the New
Hampshire Department of Labor and of the
federal oia and um it uh it's it's a bit
daunting frankly um and
um in through the process of getting
through that I mean I will admit that
when I sponsored that bill I put it
together in two
weeks um I thought it was an important
issue I thought it ought to be addressed
um I was uh embarrassingly naive when it
came to exactly what it inv involved
um it uh event it eventually went
through but the uh Governor um vetoed it
um I'm glad he did um in
2021 um I had another idea I sponsored a
bill that created a study committee to
figure out exactly what went into
creating an OSHA state
plan um that bill um and and frankly um
the the balance of power had shifted by
that time um and um
uh the other party um had taken uh
control of House and Senate um
but I was able to Prevail and in
convincing folks that um a study
committee was appropriate and needed and
um it was and actually the governor had
a signing ceremony for that study
committee um so things were moving along
in a different direction in
um I I filed HB 232 to adopt the and
this this came out of the study
committee the study committee uh
consisted of um two Democrats and two
Republicans myself and um uh Kevin
Kavanaugh Senator Kavanaugh and uh
chairman infantine at the time and um um
representative evalani and um we uh came
to a unanimous conclusion that the best
thing to do was not create the state
plan but instead to Simply adopt a
section of the osia standards that best
fit the New Hampshire public sector so
our New Hampshire Department of Labor
would still um oversee safety standards
for public sector um but they would um
have a a vast UPG grade on their um
safety standards to um ocean
standards um that um that bill passed
the committee um no no I that's wrong um
that bill was retained by the committee
I was retained by the committee
because for certain technical reasons
the study committee was delayed in
getting started um and um in the end we
had not had not opportunity to hear from
a lot of the St
stakeholders um we got through the um
the technical aspects of um uh adopting
those standards but we really didn't
hear from a lot of the employers and
such and um they let us know it um in
such a way that we figured they deserve
that opportunity so we retained the bill
and um in the fall we had a series of
meetings with those stakeholders and we
um uh we heard from them
um we also worked with the Department of
Labor um and I'm immensely grateful to
the Department of Labor for um doing
what they did which was to revamp and
amend the bill um in into the form that
you see
um unfortunately HB 232 died on the
table um it never received a vote in the
house never made it to the Senate it
didn't go to the governor um so being
determined it's back um and it's u in
the form it was
before and I'd like to go through the
key features of um HB now
303 HB 303 directs the New Hampshire
Department of Labor to develop standards
through rul making that are this is key
at least as effective as the ocean 19 10
standards that phrase is the one that
does a lot of work at least as
effective it means we we put in a hefty
dose of New Hampshire common sense into
these safety
standards for
example we heard from the Department of
Environmental Services that they have
some very expensive um air testing
equipment um designed and built in in
Europe um and purchased by the
Department of Environmental Services it
is highquality equipment does a great
job it is not OSHA
approved at least as effective takes
care of that the Department of Labor can
can go in and make the determination
that there's nothing wrong with this
equipment it doesn't have to be OS
approved it just has to be as effective
as o an OSHA approved system and on that
basis they can approve it another
example there is a town uh Hall
somewhere down toward the SE Co I want
to say e exitor but I can't remember
which one exactly but one of the Town
Halls they have a very historic building
um with a big wooden front
door um it is not up to OSHA fire
standards
but upon inspection it would work at
least as well as an OSHA approved fire
door um therefore our department of
labor can go in using common sense and
say this is not a hazard there's nothing
wrong with it it just doesn't meet OSHA
standards and we we can override that so
wherever issues like that come up as
long as it is at least as
effective it's okay um and that would
U help immensely
the bill also provides for three
provides three years for um the
department to engage in its rul making
and gearing up to be ready to uh
Implement um the uh the new
standards um I've been in communication
with the department and the um in fact I
met with them last week and
um we're wondering if maybe three years
isn't quite enough perhaps four if the
department feels that that type of
amendment would be appropriate um I'd be
you know certainly open to it I I don't
feel compelled to rush through this we
want to get it done but we want to get
it done right and we also want to have
employers have enough time to um to get
comfortable with it
um also um in the rul making process um
one of the goals of the department is to
write rules
that people can read um and understand
um they do not have to use OSHA language
and I've read some of the ocean
standards maybe some of you have it's a
little bit
dense a little bit long um so they can
boil it down into something that
employers and employees can read and
understand but it has to be at least as
effective as the ocean um it doesn't
have to be at least as confusing as the
oosha standards so um that another um
important
piece
um it also allows the department to
determine um which standards are not
relevant to public sector um Employers
in New Hampshire and not have to write
standards to to match no no reason to
write rules that are not needed in New
Hampshire so um the department can
figure that out and um where it's
unnecessary to write rules they
don't
um it also directs the department to do
an annual um review of the standards and
determine if some of them need to need
to be some new standards need to be
implemented or if um some of the current
updated it also authorizes the
department to hire six IAL inspectors in
one clerical position
um and it's key to know and I didn't
know this until partway through this
process the Department of Labor is not
funded through General funds Department
of Labor is fully funded internally um
through fees it collects uh I believe
and the Deputy Commissioner can confirm
this I believe the fees are um collected
through uh workers comp insurance
companies um but basically
um those
um those six there are seven new
employees um would would use um would be
funded through Department of Labor
Administration fund or the Department of
Labor restricted funds um so there would
not need to be an appropriation I
believe it would need to be approved by
the fiscal committee but it would not
funds a few other key
factors um I mentioned earlier that the
department has four years to uh put the
rules together um employers will
additionally have those four years to
get used to the idea and get educated by
the Department of Labor on changes that
are
happening the department uh uh the
department always has and will continue
to work with employers and I confirmed
this again last week to work with
employers to meet safety standards isn't
in a reasonable way penalties are
generally not implemented If an employer
makes a good faith effort to um comply
so the department might do a safety
inspection come in and find that um
there's a violation of some
standard
they'll they may very well warn the the
employer of what the um fine um might
be and then
they have a timetable as to when the
correct will take place if the
correction takes place in a timely and
effective way the the um fines are
generally waved so it's not a punitive
system I would think that if the um
violation is ignored nothing is done and
the department comes back and finds that
the the violation is still occurring
yeah they ought to be fined and that's
appropriate
um the department has also um always
understood that compliance might need to
accommodate a budget cycle for a public
uh employer um you can't just uh if if
if there is an expense if there's a
lighting need or something um it might
have to go through the next budget cycle
and and the department figures out a way
to have an interim uh solution um in the
meantime um there have been um issues
raised about unfunded
mandates um
the uh former deputy um commissioner
those of us who have been around for a
while remember Rudy Ogden um now judge
Ogden um but um he made it very clear
that under current circumstances the
department is put in a position of
informing employers that you've got a
safety violation that might cost you
some money to um to rectify it's always
had to do this and it's always had to
figure out a way to make that work work
um keep the workers safe don't spend
money
unnecessarily but when necessary you've
got to spend money and and frankly it's
always been found that um complying with
safety standards is not an expense it's
it's a savings because not having a safe
workplace is far more expensive uh for
employers than the
opposite and I guess the the last item
is that um at present
because the current safety standards has
holes in it substantial holes in it um
when a safety inspection takes place and
there is a condition that is clearly
unsafe however it is not covered by our
current Department of Labor safety
standards um they've got sort of a uh
safety valve um it's the general duties
Clause um and that General duties Clause
basically I I'll paraphrase I can't
quote it exactly but basically it says
you ought to have a safe workplace um
and
um and they can lean on that when
necessary to uh to say you've got to fix
this um unsafe situation and often
they'll lean on the OSHA standards to uh
sort of justify what they're doing um or
sometimes other other standards in in
the industry um but I see this that as
being grossly unfair
um an employer should be able to read
the standard and comply with the
standard the employer shouldn't be
finding out that um there's a standard
that OSHA's got that New Hampshire is
going to lean on to uh through the
general duties Clause um to hold a a uh
employer um responsible for an unsafe
situation they ought to know what the
standards are and through upgrading our
standards to standards that are at least
as effective as the oosha standards
everyone will know what the standards
are and will be able to um read them
understand them and Implement them um
I'm very proud of where where this is
now I'm uh again very grateful to the
Department of Labor they're the ones
that came up with the at least as
effective line and that is um that was a
godsend that makes this work so much
better um I uh very hopeful that we can
come up with a bipartisan support for
this um when I first presented this to
Chairman infantine he said yeah I'm with
you I'm a safety guy and he did workers
comp uh insurance and he had lost um
workers to on the job uh
injuries on job fatalities and um he he
took he takes um safety very seriously
and um um he was was a partner through
much much of this process as was
representative avalani and I am grateful
for their um their backing um so with
that I'll uh take any questions you've
got F the first of all just thank you
for a ton of work it's hard as you work
over four years which we've all done to
try to make it work so I I can see
there's a lot of been a lot of work uh
representative
Granger thank you Mr
chair so when you originally introduced
this Bill back in the day and you had
the study committee you had a senator as
part of that and if I remember correctly
and I could I I could be misremembering
it one of the problems that with the
bill last year when we were executing it
or executing it was that we found
information that the Senate was not
going to pass the Bill do we have more
Senate Buy in this year or do you not
know
or I don't recollect that the Senate was
uh put I I I'm not saying it would have
been a uh Cakewalk at the sen in the
Senate um but um uh I don't recall that
the senate had specific
problems okay okay represent kahill
thank you uh Mr chair and thank you
representative uh were you present in
the room earlier when we heard from an
attorney representing uh insurance
companies and he stated that our rates
have gone down and our safety record has
gone down due to improved safety
practices and would you would you infer
that safety practices are improved when
you have better safety standards I think
I already testified that U um strong
safety standards saves money and he was
talking about saving money on workers
comp so that's part of the savings thank
you representative
labr thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um you had
mentioned the wooden door that wasn't
ocean compliant do you see this driving
this OSHA upgrade do you see this OSHA
costs well I I
guess if there is a unsafe
situation um that needs to be corrected
that could have a cost effect but it's
also going to improve safety standards
and I did say in the in the wooden door
that if the Department of Labor would in
all likelihood let that stand um because
it it was as effective as a OA approved
door follow
up what is the current safety
requirements by do today when they do an
inspection at somebody's yard do you
know what they are meaning do they do
they require certain checklist of things
you have to have whether it's a safety
manual on the Shelf in the office or
certain items that the uh the staff
would have to have what is their safety
protocol you familiar with those I would
defer to to the department on that okay
thank
you further questions so I I got a
couple of things and and and again that
the work seems very exhaustive but I've
worked with OSHA on several cases and
the volumes of rules regulations and
requirements and OSHA could fill this
entire
room is it your assessment that the
wording that it makes sense for New
Hampshire will will prevent us from
overwhelming My Town Hall was built in
1819 I will guarantee you that the
lights the vents the windows the hatched
hatched doors all that stuff is going to
violate some sort of ocean regulation
and and how do we ensure that we don't
all of a sudden put on our
municipalities this overwhelming
requirement to
meet such volume of Regulation that
that's my biggest concern well I I I
think these Town Hall issues are often
um excuse me building standards more
than OSHA standards um but
um I think the way this this bill has
been structured um where it costs a town
or public entity money it's going to be
money well spent I think the Department
of Labor can um
avoid um creating rules that are going
to um
uh for Force um they're going to create
rules that will improve safety that's a
good thing it's also a good thing that
they will not create rules that would
simply spend money because uh of uh a
silly requirement they can get rid of
the silly requirements and actually
focus in on safety I I'm convinced of
that um and I
been meeting with the Department enough
that I I've got great confidence that um
they can do the job um and um and we'll
be a better State when it's done okay
thank you see no questions oh I'm sorry
McKenzie yes uh you can speak but then
you cannot return to ask a question the
I think the rule is if I if I may that
if if you speak from um if you testify
you can't ask questions that's correct
um but if you are
co-sponsor um you can go ahead as long
as you don't
testify okay I thought you you asked if
you could testify can I I guess can I
ask
questions have I ever denied you I've
asking a question but I believe me repr
McKenzie I'm keeping tabs and you're
number two but yes go ahead and ask your
question
uh so the question
is the question is um uh when did this
standard
pass um that covered public employees
and you may not know the answer but so
and the department may know it so as I
understand it looking at the rules the
original rules were promulgated they
were authorized in ' 86 they expired
they went back in okay are you asking a
question or are you giving
I'm trying to get to a question I guess
okay but I think I'm I don't think he's
going to I think I'm putting him on the
spot so how about put me on the spot
okay well the the question is the the
evolution of this standard are you are
you uh the current standard 1400 rules
are you familiar with the evolution of
this and how many times has expired and
it expires every 10 years and needs to
be uh reopt it the department is working
on um a read-option right now and uh
after meeting with them last week
they're looking at five sections of the
rules to um be uh revised um but every
10 every 10 years they have to be reopt
it um so that we're in that process
right now great thank you thank you okay
good thank you sir all right um thank
you for your oh I'm sorry representative
Hall go ahead thank you Mr chair uh
thank you representative Sullivan my
question you're as a few people have
commented bringing in OSHA comes with
the whole whole lot of baggage and a
whole lot of paperwork and regulations
can you talk about some of the specific
issues that you're aware of that this
would address what the benefits are of
this like specifics you know like rates
of injury that kind of thing I'm glad
you Ed the phrase bringing in OIP we are
not bringing in OIP um way back when we
did the study committee it was um
specifically decid Ed that we did not
want to have an O OSHA state plan
because um we wanted to do it the New
Hampshire way um what we are doing is we
are mirroring New Hampshire safety
regulation on making it equivalent to um
the oosha standards um and
um I can give one example there there
are no electrical standards in the um uh
Department Department of Labor um uh
standard s um obviously there are many
electrical um safety issues but in the
in the department of labor standards if
I if I I recall correctly and I hope the
Deputy Commissioner will correct me if
I'm wrong but I don't believe there are
any electrical standards there so it's
just a g gaping hole that we need to
fill follow up but my question is more
are there concrete examples of workplace
injuries lost work that sort of thing
that this would address uh the
inspiration for this
bill um was a worker and I believe it
was the town of Northwood who
um was engaged a town a town worker
um they were trying to move a um uh I
think I think it was a large trailer and
they're using um a bucket loader you two
pieces of he heavy equipment I'm not
sure exactly what they were
the
um the worker was I believe acting as a
flagger um and people lost track of
where other people were he was crushed
between the trailer and one of the
pieces of heavy equipment and was
killed
um that one
death I think is enough to justify doing
this um I I don't personally have
percentages and numbers that I can
provide to you uh the department might
be able to they do all the workers comp
so they would they would know um but uh
I don't have the statistics but
um that that was the motivation for and
frankly we had um his daughter came to
testify before this committee um two or
three different times unfortunately
she's passed um and uh isn't here
anymore she actually dedicated her life
to worker safety she um got an education
and uh frankly was um um was in the
process of um Basics she worked for a
company that went into um New Hampshire
um uh companies and helped them um
create uh safety programs that would
help and so it was uh that was part of
the
inspiration and representative King
thank you Mr chairman so a question on
the current rules the Department of
Labor has did the committee study how
detailed uh how much changes there were
from what the OSHA rules are currently I
should have said that um the department
leading up to the um work of the study
committee they spent hours and hours and
did a detailed side by side and I can
share this um with the committee if it
would if it's desirable and I would just
share there was actually three sections
of oal rules the 1910 rules were the
ones that we thought were most
appropriate um and
uh the department went through all of
the oosha rules all of the the New
Hampshire Department of Labor rules did
a side-by-side comparison in some cases
the department had um rules that uh had
similar rules with OSHA other times
there's just no rule at all in New
Hampshire um and they went completely
through that so they are well prepared
to uh to do the work um and I'd be ha
I'll just just warn you it's a big
file um but I'd be happy to share that
with the committee it um it's
uh it's just a little bit tricky opening
at the first time I as as requested if
so if people requested if you could
share that that would be great I will do
that and represent thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking the
question in your bill here you're
envisioning up to six new inspectors
labor inspectors to be funded and and my
question to you is if the Department of
Labor already has a set number of
regulations standards in
place those are being currently enforced
by the current uh staff levels you're
asking what you want to do as I
understand is to change those
regulations to make them much more
effective much more strict but there's
still going to be a number of
regulations in place just they're going
to be
different uh are you is your purpose
here to
uh wild or drastically
increase um work site investigations and
inspections by adding the staff um these
are not my my intentions the six
additional inspectors was suggested by
the department um and so I I think I'll
defer that to the department to let them
indicate exactly um how they will
operate what they're I think one of the
things they're expected to do is um to
help employers understand the safety
standards um and get them ready to um
Implement them so that they're they'll
be uh doing a fair bit of work bu
building up to it um but again the
department can it was their idea so I'll
let them explain it okay and thank you
all right good question all right sir
thank you for introducing the
bill and I'd like to call Miss Mary bour
please
and ma'am if you could State your your
please so honorable members thank you
for giving me the opportunity here this
um I have over thank you very much I
have over 20 years of experience in
Facilities Management both in the
private and public sector and while I
represent Sullivan County today the New
Hampshire Association of counties
legislative committee has reviewed hb303
and all New Hampshire counties share
concerns regarding its impact this bill
mandates OSHA level safety standards for
public employees presenting significant
financial and operational challenges for
local governments and
taxpayers hb303 does create an unfunded
mandate in Staffing burdens counties
will need to hire additional Personnel
or Consultants to manage and ensure
compliance Sullivan County anticipates
the need for one to two full-time
employees for compliance efforts which
are not budgeted and come at a time of
increased fiscal scrutiny Statewide
implementation will increase competition
for qualified safety personnel straining
resources further without dedicated
funding counties face tough budget
choices potentially leading to service
reductions or tax increases hb303
imposes a significant unfunded mandate
on counties by requiring costly building
upgrades to comply with ocean level
standards without providing any
financial assistance modernizing old
facilities such as correctional centers
cour houses Office Buildings nursing
homes and garages poses financial and
logistical challenges these structures
built before current safety standards
would require extensive retrofitting
including electrical lighting HVAC fire
safety improvements and accessibility
upgrades these expenses place an
unplanned heavy financial burden on
local governments without dedicated
funding support hb303 has an unclear
compliance timeline for covered entities
while the state has three years to
implement administrative rules the bill
does not specify the timeline for local
compliance without a phased approach
approach counties could face rushed
implementation resulting in financial
strain and operational
disruptions hb303 would introduce yet
another layer of oversight complicating
and already complex regulatory landscape
counties already operate within a
complex regulatory landscape overseeing
critical service such as Corrections law
enforcement and long-term care adding
another layer of oversight complicates
compliance with existing mandates
including criminal justice standards
accredit accreditation requirements and
Health Care guidelines aligning OSHA
equivalent standards with County
operations present significant challenge
given the unique and high-risk nature of
our work while workplace safety is a
priority hb303 imposes substantial
unfunded burdens on local governments
placing additional pay additional
pressure on our local taxpayers we
respectfully request reconsideration of
the Bill's scope time line and financial
Provisions to ensure a balanced and
achievable approach to workplace safety
consideration thank you ma'am are there
any questions representative McKenzie
and then representative Granger thank
you um I'm dragging this back from a few
years ago but my understanding is that
uh that long-term care facilities uh are
not covered by
OSHA uh that's that's my recollection
that they have their own standard and
therefore they you are currently uh
operating under a separate standard for
mosha and I believe that's the case with
prisons as well they have their own
their own standard and then
finally me I'm sorry one question at a
time yes sir please um yes that uh I
mean to me that that demonstrates how
complex it makes it because you would
have some operations within the counties
that are subject to OSHA following those
guidelines or the state as equ as
equivalent to OSHA while you have other
operations within the counties that are
um underneath their own uh accreditation
so to speak and so what it does is it
just creates more complicated layering
of which
uh which regulations actually apply and
for that reason is why we're saying that
it would create a much more complex
safety program than what we currently
have that we do feel is effective in the
way that we manage our
Workforce for followup sir thank you so
if the uh if the legislation recognized
the fact that you already have standards
in place the nationally recognized
standards and you were not covered by so
this this would we would to write you
out that
section um would that would that help
you would this be less complicated for
you given that OSHA doesn't cover this
doesn't cover those areas anyways at
this point um well there's certainly a
wide variety of of things that we do
within the county Beyond long-term care
and Corrections um I would also group
the Sheriff's Office operations within
at that probably as law enforcement um
but you know we we operate cour houses
we have Office Buildings and so I think
even if you were to exclude long-term
care and Corrections it would still
create a fractured program within the
county to be Ure that we were um we were
operating in a way that met all of our
requirements whether it was through dhh
licensing um whether it was through the
administrative rules or whatnot it it
just increases the complexity I think no
matter which way you look at it because
the counties do provide a wide variety
of very unique services that are unlike
each
other thank you thank you okay thank you
and repres Granger thank you Mr chair do
you think this bill would increase
property
taxes um I would say in most cases most
definitely not only at the county level
but also for municipalities we you know
the um the committee has also has
already talked about old facilities um
and so one of the things to think about
is over time we have these older
facilities that local governments are
operating in that have kept up with
building codes and increasing fire codes
as they've needed to um in terms of when
they do Renovations they need to bring
things up to building codes but if
buildings haven't done Renovations for a
long time you're asking now a building
that wasn't wasn't planned to have a r
any type of renovation to now meet a
modern um Safety Code that that um you
know really the local government hasn't
been in a position to factor that into
their Capital Improvement plan whatnot
so whether it's things that need to be
addressed immediately or things that
need to come longer longer term
depending on the length of time that
entities have to comply is most
definitely though those are going to
cost and that cost will be passed on to
you I seeing no further questions ma'am
thank you for coming down appreciate
thank you Mr chairman um to be clear my
name is Susie nordor and that's okay my
mom had to be creative with the spelling
so uh not your
fault I am here I work for the National
Council for occupational safety and
health and we are a nonprofit and we do
advocacy education training uh for
workers on safety in the workplace and
we support House Bill
303 um I have been involved with this
for actually even longer than
representative Sullivan because prior
to uh him submitting the bill to create
a public sector OSHA for New
Hampshire um actually I believe it was
representative McKenzie who put the
first one in um I had met the daughter
of Tom Wooten who worked for the
Northfield
DPW and um heard her story and I I would
like to fill in a few of the gaps that
representative Sullivan didn't mention
um because I think they're pertinent so
in July of 2016 Tom Wooten who worked
for the Northfield Department of Public
Works uh was working and the town had a
it's like a tractor trailer container it
wasn't the whole tractor trailer just
the the container and I don't know the
words for these so you have to forgive
me that they would move from one
location to another was a couple miles
not very far and rather than spending
$300 to $500 to hire a truck to attach
the the to carry the container from
place to place what they would do is
they would take equipment that they had
for who knows what that had I don't I
call them front loaders I think I'm
wrong with that but the buckets on the
for scooping dirt and so they had a
tractor trailer for an 18-wheeler that
they were carrying between two vehicles
and it was going down public roads so
they had um Tom Wooten as a
flagger and what happened in July of
2016 was that something jostled Tom
tried to stabilize it and he was crushed
between the uh the bucket and the truck
or the trailer or I don't know the names
of the pieces you have to forgive me I
am not a safety technical expert by any
stretch of the imagination his pelvis
was crushed and he
died and um his wife was on a business
trip it took her 12 hours to get home
she was told her husband was in the
hospital so he might be dead she she
didn't know because he didn't die right
away his daughter was at the gym she
didn't get the message she was unable to
and so his
family became a statistic basically the
family of he became a statistic of
someone killed on the
job and the New Hampshire Department of
Labor sent an inspector and the
inspector sent them a report it was
seven pages mostly pictures that just
said this
happened they didn't do uh root cause
analysis they didn't do interviews of
the people who were there there they
didn't there there were so many things
that would happen in an OSHA inspection
had Tom worked for a public or private
construction company or private whatever
company that just don't happen the
Department of Labor
did I can't say nothing because they did
take some pictures and write a report
the report didn't say anything Anyone
who reads it is flabbergasted that this
was all that they could muster for the
death of someone who was working um for
the people of the town of
Northfield so Sam his daughter um in in
April of 2017 came to an event I was
working at the New Hampshire uh
affiliate of national Kosh and we had
have every year a memorial dinner for
workers who are killed on the job the
previous year and Sam and Tom's wife
Allison and the rest of the family came
and 9 months later you could still see
this family their pain was palpable and
what I've later learned is this was Tom
had been some sort of a engineer like
Highway engineer or something um and
they moved to New Hampshire this was his
retirement job he loved to hunt he loved
to fish he loved the outdoors they came
here this was his job um before they
like retired retired and he was killed
and all of their PL
just didn't happen and so um Sam his
daughter was mad and so she talked to us
and she told us you know this is what
they they didn't even tell us anything
about what happened they didn't know and
at the time she was a college student
she was studying I think
psychology
um and so we tried to find out what
happened and we saw this report and
we're like where's this analysis and
where are all the things that you would
normally in an
OSHA level
report and so we started looking into it
representative Mckenzie was the chair of
the New Hampshire C board at the time he
looked into it he realized that and he
probably knew this anyway because he's
forever um that the department had rule
in rule they had jurisdiction over
public employees sa safety and health
but it was wasn't into statute so that
was the first thing that we did because
as you just heard the rules they expire
they do this and they do that and nobody
really knows the status of them although
I would imagine the department does but
um so in 2019 we actually um put into
statute and I the papers that I gave you
I referenced the statute that the
department has jurisdiction over public
sector
employees and I will say that the former
Deputy Commissioner
Ogden um took this very seriously and
when he heard the frankly horrifyingly
inaccurate or not inaccurate um
incomplete amount of information that
the Wooten family was given he did make
changes at the department level um to
try to to beef this
up and um and that's good I I think
Department I think
when I come to these I get so angry
because the people like Tom and he's not
the only one if you go Hazen road you
can see the memorial with all the the
the shovels for all of the Public Works
employees who've been killed on the job
Public Works people do some of the most
dangerous work in they I mean Tree
Service is like a hugely um dangerous
job who knew that um road construction
other construction these are very
dangerous jobs
and the state the Departments and the
dees does a great job they know they
have equipment they know if it's OSHA
compliant or not the towns like
Northfield don't necessarily know that
do you know what the first thing the
town did after Tom died they sent the
rest of the the department to an OSHA 10
safety training kind of like closing the
Barn Door after the horse is
dead they need support support in
getting this as the women from the
counties said the the smaller entities
that live on these shoestring budgets
and I suspect I hope that some of the
six employees that the Department of
Labor intends to add um have to do with
there's there's aspects of Osha that we
do not have um for public sector
employees that that is available for
private sector um employers which is um
sort of like a consult program coaching
and Consulting so that the employers can
actually for free have someone come and
look and tell them these are the things
that an ocean Spectre will find and
here's the things that you can do to um
to bring yourself up to code because
what happens when you run the way that
we're running now where everybody has
their own thing and if you have the
money and the expertise inh housee great
if you don't it's the employees it's the
people who work work for our towns and
our counties and our
schools they're the ones who bear the
risk it's families like the Wooten
family who lost Tom's income for the
rest of his life he I believe he was in
his 50s so he had you know 10 more years
of working they lost his companionship
they lost his granddaughter lost her
grandfather his daughter lost her father
the family was devastated by his death
and that's just one of I think since
2000 it was something like 40 I believe
it was maybe one or two a year um
between all levels and that's as
comprehensive as we could get some of
them aren't recorded some of them aren't
even considered there's workers comp
issues that um if somebody's rejected
they don't I mean there are so
many large entities that are on the side
of who's paying and what's going on and
so few of us who really are here to say
what is the right thing to do for the
people who work for this company like
Tom because I actually after the I I met
the inspector who did this pathetic
excuse for a report um I had lunch with
her and what I want to tell you is that
she told me she's like yeah you know I
mean what they were doing was obviously
crazy but there's no law that says you
can't do that
and I said to her I'm like what about
the general duty clause which literally
says you can't do crazy things maybe not
literally but it does it says you have a
general duty to provide
safe work to your employees and we in
the state have said that we know you
have that's that's inst State Statute
already even at the time in
2016 and the but the inspector the
person who looked at
this was like yeah it kind of his fault
cuz he was being too conscientious he
tried to fix something and now this is
you know I mean if this was a court of
law The Rules of Evidence don't apply
it's hearsay um but just so you know
this is why Professional Standards that
are right now in at this moment right
now all of the private employers that
are over a certain size in the state of
New Hampshire are are subject to so
we're not asking towns and cities to do
anything more than we ask our small
businesses to do we aren't we're asking
them simply to protect their workers the
human beings who are the ones who bear
the risk when the their employers can't
be bothered to do the least and and
people in my industry the health and
safety industry for what for lack of a
better word consider Osan standards a
bare
minimum and if you look
at probably the ones the long-term care
standards that they're using at the
county level they're going to pass by
this because they'll probably be higher
lots of of
professional um associations have higher
than that and that's fine that's always
great but OSHA is a bare minimum and I
think that we owe our public sector
employees our neighbors our friends that
bare minimum as well thank you thank you
ma'am for your compelling testimony are
any questions representative Granger
thank you Mr chair you mentioned a um uh
some sort of general rule in OSHA that
says don't do crazy stuff more or less
yes the general duty Clause I so I is is
that just a OSHA
regulation the general duty Clause it is
an OSHA regulation but it is also one of
the when in 1986 as representative
McKenzie said when they first put some
of the OSHA standards that's been an
OSHA standard for as long as OSHA's been
around so since 1970 and that basically
the it Duty what it means is the
employer has a general duty anything
that is not enumerated in this you know
mountain of rules and regulations would
get which get ridiculously specific I
would 100% admit but there is the one
that says if it's obviously unsafe
MH as if like a sane person would say
you shouldn't be doing that cuz
someone's going to get hurt or killed
then the department can site someone and
and as representative Sullivan explained
that right now they use that in places
where um there might be either an OSHA
standard or a a professional association
standard they reference those but they
they actually would site someone under
the general duty to provide safe work so
like if you have an electrical panel
that has like a leak dripping right on
top of it and there's like sparks flying
out of it and you're like whoa that's
dangerous they would cite that under
general duty cuz which was as we just
heard they don't have anything on
electricity in the New Hampshire rules
so and then what the inspector at the
New Hampshire do would do is they'd
probably look at whatever code and
electrical code or something like that
that they thought was appropriate and
they would say this is what we suggest
you do to remedy it but the citation
would actually be under this general
duty which already exists today in New
Hampshire I think it's the 1400 rule but
I could be wrong for a clarification
question yes so you are you referring to
a state law or an OSHA standard is this
an OSHA standard or a state La both um
it was originally an OSHA standard and
then in 1980 Something um the department
put several OSHA standards into I
believe it's the 1400 rule but don't
quote me on that um and the general duty
Clause is one of
those okay okay thank you you're welcome
questions representative Hall if I
understand you correctly and first of
all let me preface my question this is a
horrible story tragic I understand
everybody's heartbroken um but if I'm
understanding you correctly there was
already a rule against doing what was
done when this tragedy occurred there
was and so you would think that the
inspector would have said doing this
crazy thing that again here say people
driving by said someone's going to get
hurt or killed doing that um everybody
who looked at it could say this is
insane why are you doing it this way
spend the $300 to get a truck to take it
um but the inspector for whatever reason
said there's not a law that specifically
says you can't carry a trailer between
two trucks that weren't designed for
carrying trailers
and so she didn't do any she so she did
not site the town of
Northfield for a followup quick
follow-up
so the difference that this bill would
bring is a different set of standards
for writing the report after the
accident occurred is that accurate
honestly yes it would bring some of
those but what it would also bring is
training for the Department's inspectors
so that they would know what general
duty means because I as a lay person can
understand it but apparently at that
time and I my understanding is that
since that time they are um a lot more
attentive to such things but at that
time the
inspector just general duty didn't occur
to
her okay and representative
McKenzie um thank you for referencing
1985 by the way uh I was still in the
question I have is you have two
employers you have a a state employee or
local Town employee and you have a um a
private employer work on the same road
in the same town right next to each
other so what rules apply to the private
sector
worker does ooser apply
there as long as the company is large
enough yeah if it's like a sole
proprietor probably not and the and the
other side of the street those that are
not working the ones that are working
for the public sector entity are um
subject to whatever's in the do rules
right now right okay but it's not an the
yosha stand so the point being if I
could two different two different sets
of standards for those people that are
working in the same road well and the
thing that I find really interesting is
that nobody from federal Osan they have
an office here in New Hampshire and they
come to the New Hampshire Memorial
dinner every year so I talk to some of
their inspectors and um have told them
what I'm I'm working on and they're all
like oh you know I see road construction
or this or that all the time that if we
were looking at it wouldn't be done the
way it was being
done but you know you can't get one of
them to come in here and tell you that
on the you know in public
but the towns and cities do the best
that they can I'm not saying that they
don't appreciate their employees I don't
Northfield built a like a little
Monument to
Tom
um but they are under tremendous
tremendous pressure from those who say
cut cut cut don't spend don't spend and
safety is one of those things that even
though and if you look at the page two
of my testimonies on page one page two
has some links I hope you'll email me
and I'll send you the actual Live Links
or you can type them in whatever that
talk about what would actually save
money is to take care of your employees
and do things right rather than have to
buy build a ma monument and to them
later and this is you know I talk about
Tom Wooten because it's a dramatic
instance if you figure that public
workers are 10 to 15% of the workforce
think of how many workers comp cases
that is how many slips trips falls
struck by um electrocutions the common
uh things that happen to people at work
that are so easily preventable and the
costs to prevent them are minimal it's
put a sign up move this don't you know
the things that say this base to remain
open those kinds of things the large
majority of the cost in the system is
not Tom wooten's fatality the largest
costs are the simple things that just
don't occur to people because when you
go to work and you do the same thing
every day you see the same thing every
day it doesn't necessarily occur to you
that if we kept this thing clear people
wouldn't trip but an ocean ins Spector
would come in and say you keep this
clear and then you don't have those and
that's what I would say probably 75% of
the benefit of putting this bill in
would
accomplish thank you ma'am I appreciate
it and if I could call uh Miss Albert
and please introduce yourself and your
organization and looking forward to your
testimony thank you very much I'm
Danielle Albert I'm the Deputy
Commissioner of the New Hampshire
Department of Labor I'm here today with
John garan who is the Department's
general counsel um so maybe as a
beginning point the department is has
reviewed the proposed language uh
representative Sullivan had referenced
in his testimony that he has worked with
the Department uh in relation to this
bill um and we U he did a very lovely
job I think introducing it um just by
way of summary the department
understands the proposed language to be
requiring us to um uh promate and
develop regulations uh through the
administrative rule process that are at
least as safe as the ocean 1910 uh
standards and protections there is some
Authority that's granted to the
commissioner through the proposed
language to determining which of those
standards may be inapplicable uh to New
Hampshire um and it also requires annual
review and Reporting uh annual review of
the standards that have been developed
uh with determinations as to whether or
not new standards need to be added
altered or changed as well as making
recommendations to the legisl uh
legislature based off of those uh based
off of those annual reviews um so that's
our understanding of what the the uh
proposed language is doing um as
representative Sullivan had noted during
his introduction of the bill um this
would be done through the rul making
process uh the department has safety
rules that pertain to the public
employment sector those rules really
come from um several statutory
authorities uh they come from RSA 277
they come from 281 a64 and culminate in
the uh 1400 rules which are where the
safety standards uh the current safety
standards exist um the department is
currently working on those rules
representative Sullivan had had
referenced that when he introduced the
bill um and in working on those rules
they are due for Wholesale reopt in
April of this year um but what we have
done uh is is looked at them and tried
to identify you know specific areas
where gaps need to be filled where they
they could be um enhanced or modified uh
to provide additional protections um the
sections we are looking at relate to
confined spaces and some other areas
that we've identified as needing perhaps
um as needing increased safety uh
Provisions our intent whether this
language passes or not is to continue
working on those rules um certainly if
this passes there will be a statutory
mandate that um specific uh that
specific
um OSHA esque standards are are brought
into those rules um some questions had
come up or some commentary had come up
related how to how much time uh the
department would need there's currently
within the statute there's a a
three-year post-effective date time
frame uh the department would estimate
perhaps four years maybe better
representative Sullivan had um had
referenced uh deferring to the
department on time frame we would
anticipate that the four years would
allow the department to fully draft
those rules and go through the gel car
uh process I always forget exactly what
gel car stands for but the joint
legislative action committee uh who is
the legislative body that's responsible
for putting rules through um our hope
would be to be able to promate those
rules in sections but you know from
start to finish it can take up to six
months for rules to go through gel car
so incorporating in the drafting process
you know coming up with the language
that would be relevant for the rules and
then putting it through that process um
we think four years would would probably
be enough time that would also give the
department time to hire these staff
persons that are referenced within the
bill as well as get those individuals
trained um kind of relative to cost um
the department can comment on cost to
the department itself we have put within
the fiscal note that we were asked to
provide our estimated cost of of what it
would of cost incurred by the department
in order to put these changes into place
um it is premised upon the seven staff
persons that are referenced within the
statute um there is also a component
related to spacing the Cur Department's
current space is not big enough to hold
seven additional staff persons we would
need to look for new um new building
space in order to uh increase uh
increase our staffing by that
size
um uh addressing um some of the other
testimony um the department has
testified in the past you know relative
to uh relative to um safety as regulated
by the department as it currently stands
we've acknowledged in the past and we
continue to acknowledge you know we do
need to do a good job and a better job
you know with safety um I am comfortable
reporting and I believe my pred assessor
had also reported we have made some
changes over the past several years
relative to improving the quality of
inspections how inspections go forward
uh training um and qualifications for
our inspectors and relative to report
writing um so that it is an improved uh
and a more quality product um again
regardless of whether this legislation
passes it's our intent to continue
making those improvements um and it's a
goal that we continue to have
um and I'm happy to entertain or to take
any questions uh if there are
any represent
Drago thank you Mr chair we've heard
basically there two two standards is the
OSHA standard and then the safety
standard that we have for the public
sector the consensus is that the OSHA
standard creates a much safer workplace
my question is do you have numbers to
show if we take the same type of worker
uh say tree worker uh Parks and
Recreation that um maybe cutting grass
is the incident of injuries reported per
capita higher in the public sector or
the private
sector I don't have direct numbers
available with me today my general
recollection is I I believe lower but I
would like to get the firm numbers for
you so um if if it's agreeable I'm happy
to go back to the department and we can
look at the we can pull some data um to
give to the committee showing um you're
looking for the comparison between
public and private sector is that
correct yes if you could do that that
would be great yeah okay yeah okay and
are you the information that we would
have would be based on injuries so
you're looking for reported injuries
okay representative labber thank you Mr
chair Deputy Commissioner Albert it
doesn't go you don't go much higher on
the ladder than you are so this question
hoping you can answer it um do you feel
that your Department's standard
for safety inspections are inferior to
oer OSHA's standards and do you feel
overhaul thank you for the question um
it's a very good question I I don't know
how I would go about or how the
department would go about rating
inferiority um you know I think as the
department has previously testified as
we've testified today uh certainly there
can always be improvements that are made
and we've already taken some steps uh
towards improving um th some of those
standards um our understanding of the
ENT of this proposed language is to um
bring forward a more more Harmony
between o requirements and what's
currently required by um by by state
regulation and and state statute um so
there are differences between the two I
think it's fair to say that there are
differences between the two there are
some similarities as
well please and just real quickly you
had you had made mention that there was
a need for more space more real estate
um um are we talking a new building or
are we talking what do you think we're
talking here Renovations new building
that's very good question I think more
likely than not uh probably a new
building um it's a little bit unclear to
us at this point in time uh the
department is currently at full capacity
in the sense that we are um out of space
to to seat literally seat new employees
where we to hire any so with seven new
positions we would more likely than not
need new space uh the building we're
currently in is one that's rented we do
not own it um so we very well may need
to look at renting a new space thank you
Deputy
Commissioner representative hall and
then representative
McKenzie thank you uh Mr chair uh
question the Bill calls
for funding new inspector positions but
strikes me that OSHA regulations are a
moving Target and you would need some
amount of Staffing to track those and
make sure you're staying in compliance
could you do that with existing staff or
would you need additional people to do
that thank you for the question it's an
excellent question you know currently uh
one as this language is proposed and is
written there would need to be tracking
relative to the oia standards but if
osia standards changed um it wouldn't be
the same as incorporating them by
reference in the sense that whatever the
federal government is doing would W by
word be drawn into uh the state level um
we do have individuals within the
department who assist in tracking um
legislative changes both both at the
federal and at the state level um so I
believe we would more likely than not
have sufficient Staffing to look at uh
the changes and to keep a breast of them
such that we were able to be making
decisions uh through those annual
reviews about what would need to change
what would need to be incorporated in I
think it would be more the uh more
robust um and inspections uh to have
individuals going out and actually
performing those working with the
employers providing the education on the
the new changes how to stay in
compliance and to work with them on um
mitigating or or correcting any uh any
violations that may be
found so I
guess very compelling testimony on the
need to improve safety standards some of
that is the regulatory requirements some
of that is a culture of safety and some
of that is is
enforcement what this law as I
understand having listened to it now for
the last
hour what this law does is it says hey
here's amount of regulations let's pick
and choose which ones make the most
sense for New
Hampshire
and my question is as the person there's
someone going to do it someone the
department later is going to say okay I
want that one that one and that
one and the compelling testimony of
Representative Solomon is this is going
to make sense for New
Hampshire but really make sense for New
Hampshire comes down to that
person that is picking and choosing and
what are the checks and balances then in
the Department of Labor has said he
doesn't pick all of it I mean I'm not
saying he would
but how's that check and balance so that
the municipalities are I talk to my
municipality every day and I talked to
three constituents last night whose
property tax went up by
100% And and so here I am saying okay
how am I going to approve this law and
there's no check and balance say that
the cost of this isn't going to be
exorbitant when it goes down to the town
level recognizing that I completely
agree with the premise of the of the of
changing it that that's where I'm stuck
yeah it's a good question as I
understand from the proposed language um
the the checks and balance I believe
that you're referencing would come um
potentially from two places one it would
come through those annual reviews that
the department or the commissioner
through the department is mandated to do
um there's record that's required to be
maintained of that that has to be
provided to any interested party on
request and the other check and balance
would more likely than not come through
the administrative rule process itself
which is a public process when any
Department not just the Department of
Labor uh is initiating the rul making
process there are periods uh in which
they for public comment in which the
rules are are posted they're reviewed
the public comes in they provide uh
their feedback um and then it goes
through the the gel car process where
that that commentary is is also at issue
um so there would be the ability for the
public to comment as well about whether
or not you know a rule that has been
drawn in or has been um that has been
written to be at least as effective as
an ocean 1910 standard um is has makes
sense doesn't make sense um and and that
is a form of check and balance okay
thank you you're
welcome represent McKenzie thank you uh
I know that somebody asked you for
reports uh the only thing I ask you uh
when you're reporting that out is that
you take into consideration the the
private sector numbers so compared to
the public sector so you know 25
injuries with thousand employees much
different 25 injuries with 10,000
employees yes um yes we will and I
understood the request to be um in
regard to to proportionality between the
two can you share the uh with this if I
could just share with this committee the
annual report you got by annual report
yes sir injuries yeah a good question oh
yes I'm Happ to send them out to the
committee they are also posted on our
website should you ever wish to um hop
on and just take a look
okay represent
avalani thank you Mr chairman thank you
Deputy Commissioner um for five years
we've been listening to this um and
numerous times we've heard testimony
that we're working on it we're working
on it we're working on it what sections
of rules have you changed to adopt
partial oia standards up to this point
yes thank you for the question um I want
to just be clear they have not yet
completed the gel car process so we're
in the process of of writing them um
they are due to go forward in April of
this year so in the next month or two
the sections that we are working on are
in relation to confined spaces um we are
looking at flammables and combustibles
ladders um wires rigging um the name of
that whole section it's wires riggings
okay thank you again for your patience
and your
cards on
hb303 this closes the hearing on hbo3
303 we've got about an hour left uh we
got two bills to consider and uh my
sensing is we'll we'll press and uh work
on those two bills um but will finish at
4:30 so we'll make a final assessment uh
378 and so I'd like to open the hearing
stre
all right representative
K uh what we're going to do judging by
the number of cards that just came in I
went from one to 100 in about 4 and a
half seconds uh which is a speeding
violation um we're going to punt on
we're going to recess on 378 today and
we'll take that up next week okay in
favor of 7:35 which we'll address today
okay if that works for you it works fine
okay with
apologies so I'd like to close the
hearing on 378 I apologize we just run a
little bit behind and uh we got a lot of
7:35 the amendment yeah
right and we will start the hearing on
never
he said he said to me you are the archiv
y stuff was pretty interesting they
moved it in a really good
yes
sir
e
all right good afternoon everyone and uh
I appreciate your patience long day
we're getting a lot done um I'm going to
open the hearing on HB 735
FN relative to elections and collabor
and collab collective bargaining and I'd
like to open with representative Granger
who will introduce his Bill thank you Mr
chair members of the committee so this
bill is basically just term limits for
unions uh unions should represent their
members and if they do a good job of it
then it should be no problem to restify
them at um when it comes time for that
and uh if not then they should be able
to switch which Union is representing
them and so that's essentially what this
bill does the mechanism that this bill
uses is is when the majority of the
workers were not there for the initial
vote so if a significant amount of time
goes by um then they would have to go up
for recertification and they would have
to do another vote to uh uh certify the
union and another way you could go at it
if uh that's more preferable to the
committee is just do it on a time scale
so for instance in some states they just
do it every five years and in other
states they do it every 10 years and
basically we need this in order to make
sure that unions aren't just
perpetually protecting their little fom
and saying this is our workplace and we
own it forever they the workers would
have the opportunity to say okay well
you know thanks for all your help over
the years but we think that we need a
different Union supporting us because we
have needs that are unmet or whatever
the case may be if you want to think
about it in terms of regular politics um
we don't elect Kings um in America um we
have a president and uh he lasts four
years and if he do doesn't do a very
good job then uh we vote for someone
else and uh this this just extends that
like are there any questions represent
McKenzie So currently unless I'm
mistaken there is within the um the law
the ability for a union to petition to
decertify the local union and to come up
with a whole another uh Union uh
representative if they
want are you suggesting that that's not
sufficient to uh to to meet the test
that if people are unhappy with what
they currently have that uh that that
structure is not good enough well you
and I know that a union would never use
intimidation or tactics of that nature
in order to scare people against
decertifying a union but there is an
impression among many workers that that
is the case
so this this just makes sure that
everyone knows there's a regular either
a regular schedule or when um the union
is
sufficiently distan from when they were
certified we'll just do a
recertification and that way you don't
have to put pressure on certain members
of the Union as to you know oh will they
topic okay any other questions
your bill makes reference to both the
Department of Labor and the Public
employe Public Employee Labor Relations
Board um which of them actually has
jurisdiction over public sector um
unions the ladder I
believe followup for a followup um why
is the department of labor included in
this bill then because they would have
to keep track so the other way that we
could do this is we could just have it
on a Time based system where it's like
every five years um right now they would
need to keep track of who was working
for the company when the certification
occurred um that way when the majority
of the employees in that Union are no
long weren't there for the vote they
could say well now we get to do a
recertification um I don't believe that
would be the case if uh I I could be
wrong about this so I'll put that caveat
in if we had a 5-year scheme a 10-year
scheme instead that I don't believe that
they would need to be uh counting horses
sense representative K thank you Mr
chair and thank you representative for
taking my
question um would the labor department
be in charge of finding out whether or
not the new employees had joined the
Union uh or were paying agency fees or
fair share agreements would it would
that be another requirement on your
database no they would just have just
when they started working there and when
you seeing no further questions thank
you for your
thank you and I'm happy to see
representative Fairington you're here
safe and sound I heard you had an
exciting day my name is Melissa
Lichfield I am a state representative
representing the towns of Brentwood
Danville and Fremont I am a co-sponsor
on this bill and naturally I'm here to
support it unionized employees should
have the power to pick which Union is
representing them only about 7% of the
private sector union members have ever
had a say in which union represents them
and the percentage for many public
employee unions is even lower since most
government unions were founded in the
1960s and70s few of any of the public
employees who voted for these unions are
still on the job unionized employees
should be empowered to choose on a
regular basis what union if any will
represent them and this is not about
taking power away from the unions it is
about empowering the members this is
what the union should be all about I
just wanted to share personally I had
served on two different school boards
one for nine years one for six years um
I negotiated many collective bargaining
agreements um and also M during Co I
just have found that um I think many
times the members ship was not aware of
what the leadership was bringing to us
whether it be um contract negotiation
stipulations or grievances I think that
some of the members would have been
embarrassed or horrified to have seen
some of that so I just think that this
is great for accountability and as I
said we're all about choice this is the
United States of America thank you thank
you ma'am any
questions see no questions thank you for
your testimony thank you for no
Kenny Mr chair and members of the
committee please turn your mic on and uh
if you could just state your name and
affiliation for the record um long day
for you thank you all for being here and
sticking with it um for the record my
name is Gail Kenny I am a pastor with
the United Church of Christ which some
people also know it as the
congregational churches um and I am here
on behalf of the economic Justice
Ministry of the Statewide um United
Church of Christ and also on behalf of a
number of other clergy um throughout the
state of New Hampshire and um we we
understand uh that some folks um don't
like unions and that is you know that's
that's fine it really is we all have our
own way of sort of approaching things
and looking at different things but um
for this particular bill um Faith
communities across the state are um
vigorously opposed to House Bill 735 and
we strongly urge um in expedient to
legislate but I also want to put on my
management hat um and I have uh
previously been a part of management in
the public sector and I would say this
bill um as written right now from U my
viewpoint from management
is stunningly
unworkable and um it also to to uh from
my perspective again the management
perspective and the public sector
amounts to a really bureaucratic
unfunded mandate the idea that um the
Department of Labor would have to in um
every single one of and uh the fiscal
note says that there are at least or
approximately
678 public sector bargaining units in
the state of New Hampshire and that each
one of those 678 units or even more as
they occur have to track every single
worker when they started and then uh the
Department of Labor has to get that
information which is constantly changing
as there is a change over in employees
and determine at any given point in time
that um some of those people were not
members when the union um came into
existence or was recertified or or
whatever is is it really is mindboggling
in terms of how that would work in 678
workplaces in the state of New Hampshire
so the other thing that just find I want
to say that unions are Dynamic
organizations um unions are the workers
the union is not a third party workers
make up the unions workers uh the a
majority of workers bring about a bring
a union into being not somebody else the
workers themselves in that particular
workplace and they get to vote on
whether or not those Union exists they
get to vote on who the officers are they
get to vote on what the contract says
and um it's an ongoing basis of workers
having a voice already on the job in
every single public sector workplace
wherever there is a union and um so the
the bill in its totality is uh just so
again un unworkable that if you really
think about it if you go through the
bill line by line and determine what
it's really asking for uh I would hope
that this committee would see
that it is not workable and is not
necessary for the workers who make up
the unions in New Hampshire and keep
them going so I would uh request
legislate okay any questions
for Reverend
Kenny seeing n thank you man' I
testimony and uh can I have Glenn
and Sir if you could state your name and
then um your affiliation thank you so
much thank you Mr chairman uh for the
record my name is Glenn Brackett I'm the
president of the New Hampshire AFL CIO
and a 45-year member of the
International Brotherhood of Electrical
Workers and for the last decade I've had
the honor and the privilege of being the
president of the New Hampshire AFL CIO
filling some very large Sho very large
shoes uh my organization represents over
15 Affiliated labor unions 40,000
workers in New Hampshire and uh
including our First Responders postal
workers firefighters police officers
it's more importantly our uh Building
Trades our school teachers and we're
here today to oppose House Bill 735
FN and uh I know you've had a long day
here so I'm not going to go through my
repaired remarks I just think that this
is the waste of all of our time you look
at the fiscal notes the fiscal notes are
aggressively aggressively
underestimating the cost of this um and
I think we're better served moving the
people's work into something that is
less union busting and more proactive
thank you Mr chairman okay thank you for
your brief comments do we have questions
representative
lir thank you Mr chair um president
bracket have any of
your members of any of the unions that
are being being talked about here asked
for something like this not to my
knowledge no all right thank
questions representative kessing thank
you Mr chair so I have a question I I
heard it mentioned that there is there
is a possibility there's a way for this
to happen inside the union I know you
represent a lot of them sure so could
you explain that maybe a little bit well
in in federal laws there's the ability
to decertify a union if people don't
want to be part of a union they fill out
cards and they can call for Union
election those are the processes in
place with what this bill is calling for
place so I got a question I'm just
trying to understand
um so I joined for example I'm a ski
patroller F you yeah and um
my organization went on strike in Utah
two weeks
ago and so if I were to
join that Union
MH
and not know anyone I don't know anyone
there I've never voted for him MH um
I've never signed up for him but that's
the union that's in my organization sure
I would have to and and I was not
satisfied with that leadership that in
order to get rid of them I would have to
go through a
process um and sort of a bottomup revolt
against that leadership is that I'm
sorry if that seems I mean that's just
sort of my understanding but I don't
well that makes sense too we have to
understand first of all unions are
democratic organizations if you don't
like the leadership every member every
member of the Union gets a vote and you
have if you have just like all of you
sitting here if you do a lousy job your
membership will vote you out unions are
democratic organization that's what we
do if you can't do that and enough
people are on the same page as you then
you can absolutely just desertify your
union and you can find another Union or
you can go
non-union okay and so for a followup
question then that vote you said you can
vote them out when does that occur after
enough cards assigned when you have
enough members of your organization
enough members of the Bing unit that
want to change representation they have
that ability yes okay and and that
number is that in federal law or is that
in Union rules how it's not Union rules
it would be and I'm not I think it's in
state law and federal law is it state
and federal law I think it's in both
yeah okay great thank you for the thank
you for chairman
273a
okay and representative Kine you have
another question thank you Mr chair so I
have a followup to that so the question
that i' have is how many times has that
happened uh that in the state oh boy um
there's it's happened um it's happened
quite a bit in the public sector yeah
but put a specific number on
it great thank you representative kahill
and then representative Schultz thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr bracket
the process you describe for
decertifying is that rather similar to
the process to certify a union yes it's
the number of cards yep thank you okay
representative Schultz thank you Mr
chair haven't uh some unions in New
Hampshire I can think of one prominent
Union who had considered even swapping
to a a different International yes you
um that happens that can happen as well
right it Happ it happens more often than
you would think where you want to still
have a union but not that Union there
there's a history here in New Hampshire
of unions um bargaining units changing
your representation for exactly that
reason representative
suin thank you for taking my question um
is it accurate to say that uh since this
is a public sector bill that this would
be governed this would be dealing with
273a I don't want to answer that because
I'm not sure what the whole statute of
273a speaks to
Brian
I since I represented public sector
unions for 25 years I can assure you
that RSA 273a is the
really y all right subject to any
questions thank you sir oh I'm sorry
represent
McKenzie so um thank you Mr President
bracket
So based on your experience the 45 years
in in the labor movement and I know
you've negotiated many contracts because
I've stood next you many times so tell
me what this would be like uh in in a
union if every few years they're
required to
stand uh for an election how would this
impact
bargaining uh the flow of work yeah uh
if all this is happening constantly
rumbling uh uh this uh this whole setup
that we currently have what impact would
that have on delivering Services well I
think um the way you phrase the question
it's apparent to all what would happen
it would be it would be um it would be
uh uh
just Quagmire I guess is the word I'd
use nothing would move forward um but
I'd also put it out this way you know
what if every what if every year instead
of every two years members of this
legislature had to go up for re-election
if it was every
year well so that's the answer to my
question
good afternoon chair members of the
committee uh for the record once again
my name is Brian will the president of
the professional firefighters of New
Hampshire uh we represent 43 local
unions throughout the granite state um I
will be super brief as you've seen me
enough today I speak here today in
opposition to House Bill 735 uh and just
to Echo a couple of the remarks that
we've already heard uh yes
representative McKenzie there is a
decertification ation process in place
that has worked for many years um and
it's worked well um I also heard the
question asked whether or not locals
have decertified and exercised that
process it has worked um we've seen it
in our organization we've seen um folks
decertify and move to a different labor
organization we've seen folks decertify
from a different labor organization and
come with the professional firefighters
um collabora collaboratively throughout
the state the unions work very well
together we have a harmonious
relationship with one another um so we
do not prevent any members right um from
leaving one labor organization and
moving on to another um the the idea
that there may be a a strong arming of
sorts to keep members involved in the
union just simply does not occur um at
least in our profession here in New
Hampshire um and so I just want to quell
that rumor to begin with also I'd like
to to say that I think it's interesting
that we talk about empowering unions um
and and and there was a fairly lengthy
uh discussion on right to work uh
previously and even many proponents of
Right to Work say that it's about
choosing a labor organization and
members choose to certify as a labor
organization with a certain Union and
they have that right as it stands right
now to leave um if they uh choose to
exercise that right that's great if
they're forced
every so often um it's going to lead to
a Slowdown in as representative McKenzie
mentioned uh the the operations it's
going to lead to a lack of Harmony
within the labor and management
collaborative and it also has unintended
consequences of impacting the other side
of the table so while the thought might
be that this may weaken unions I a don't
believe that to be true and B I believe
the unintended consequences are that it
affects the management side uh in that
it's costly it's timec consuming and
it's problematic um and it increases
anxiety amongst the workforce so I would
ask you all to respectfully uh oppose
this legislation thank you thank you for
your testimony are there any questions
around the
table saying no questions thank you sir
I appreciate you long
um thank you m excuse me uh thank you Mr
chairman for the record Brian Hawkins
representing Nea New Hampshire uh we
represent um over
17,000 um Educators across the state uh
in uh quite a few
locals um and we're here in opposition
to um hospit
7:35 um a lot of what I had prepared has
been said already so I'll I'll just
summarize and I do have written
testimony I can hand in please thank you
uh so we we feel like House Bill
735 is nothing more than an attack on
collective bargaining and unions and
would make it harder for unions to fight
for things that make a difference for
our members and for their students our
members bargain for higher wages and
benefits so we can retain and attract
the best Educators possible to educate
the Next Generation and we're also
advocating to make sure that our
workplaces which are also our CL
classrooms and our schools are safer
places to learn um the bill inserts
what's already been brought up as a
bureaucratic uh nightmare of a process
to determine bargaining units and as was
stated before there is already a process
to do that and I think it's important to
emphasize that that process is done by
the workers it is the workers choice to
uh form a union it should be Theirs to
if they want to D certify their Union
and as was described earlier there is
already a process to do that so uh we
would respect this bill actually has
come before the New Hampshire
legislature before in
2020 um I believe it's the exact same
language and this was
overwhelmingly uh defeated
recommended uh by this committee um itl
and so we would ask that uh this
committee do that once again and we can
move on to other things so thank you
very much for your time and happy to
take any
questions are there any questions
representative
McKenzie so the first uh the first
sentence I believe of the Public
Employee lab relations law is is are
there to promote harmonious relations
among the employees and the employers so
tell
me if you have a
situation where this C this
ongoing ongoing process is disrupting
bargaining it's disrupting relationships
with employees how does that meet the
test of promoting harmonious relations
uh for the for the organization and for
that's the law or the land that's that's
what we're working on thank you for the
question um and I would say it doesn't
promote that at all does the exact
opposite in fact as I mentioned at the
top of my
testimony uh it really um moves away
from the whole purpose uh the other
purpose that uh unions are there for
which is to represent and to fight for
their members and this um uh uh takes up
um resources bandwidth time um uh rather
than uh trying to make sure that their
so okay see no further questions please
uh if you could give the clerk the
testimony that would be
next good afternoon Mr chairman
honorable members of the committee for
the record my name is Richard gulla
president of the state employees
Association of New Hampshire I represent
10,000 hardworking newshire for public
employees and
retirees I'll be brief I know it's been
a long day for all you folks and I have
uh written testimony that I can submit I
just want to highlight a few things from
it um let me start with two blunt
questions why would this bill be a
priority for elected officials why would
someone want to Target and restrict
freedom of people simply because they
are members of the Union given the
complexities and challenges we are all
facing this legislative session we are
now especially in need to be working
together not advocating breaking people
apart some of you may know that this
past weekend the New Hampshire GOP
passed a resolution relating to union
members it was passed with broad support
by those present for the New Hampshire
gop's annual meeting the resolution
stated the following be it resolved that
the New Hampshire GOP welcomes
workingclass Granite Staters including
union members
into our expanding big tent as we make
America great
again the intent and contents of House
Bill 735 is a complete contradiction to
welcoming working Granite stators which
is most certainly includes union
members supporters of this bill are
trying to restrict the freedom of nurses
teachers firefighters police officers
and other public employees to come
together to have their voice heard these
folks who serve our community have the
right to protect their retirement and
health care as they see fit and anti-un
extremists in our state capital are
trying to restrict to that end our right
we know that we have worked in good
faith with numerous sponsors of this
bill and we hope we can quickly return
to that Dynamic and work together to
deliver on our promises to the Granite
State and with that I'll conclude I'll
pass this in and I would ask you to uh
pass this in expedient to legislate
thank you for your input and your
testimony representative Schultz do you
have a question this will be quick um I
know be in recent years it that the
breakdown of your membership essentially
matched the proportion of party
representation as the whole state is
that still the case uh pretty it's
changed it used to be a third third and
a third um I I now have more registered
Republicans that I represent than
Democrat rats and then more Independence
which does follow the state there are
more registered Independence now but
it's Independence Republicans and
Democrats I have a lot of Republican
members that are active that um it's
like sticking a poking their eye with a
stick with these type of pieces of
legislation they're hardworking citizens
and they're taxpayers and they're
they're
Republicans thank you sir for your
testimony
please good afternoon chairman it's a
pleasure to be here in front of the
labor committee again my name is Deborah
how I am president of the American
Federation of teachers New Hampshire and
I represent prek through 12 uh Educators
and School staff across the state as
well as private and public University
faculty and uh Town employees across the
Granite State uh I am here today in
opposition of HB
735 uh frankly put this bill is
something that would tie up our public
employee unions in uh a mountain of red
tape and it it would make it harder for
us to do our job representing our
members and uh making it harder for us
to serve the people in our communities
and do our job JS well uh this bill is a
solution in search of a problem and the
people we're talking about in this bill
are my members they are um you know
teachers and Par Educators who educate
our children in schools in our
communities uh they are the um Public
Works employees who drive the plow truck
and you know sand the road so you can
drive on your road safely and get home
these are people who deserve the right
to join together and collectively
bargain raise their voices get a good
wage have a Secure Retirement and you
know have a say in their working
condition so that they can do their job
safely serve the communities well and
come home to their families afterwards
um unions are the way to level the
playing field and the granite state by
the way supports unions we recently
conducted uh we recently got information
from a bipartisan poll from Raba
research that said Granite State voters
this poll was just conducted last week
at finished um yesterday and 90% of
Granite State voters approve of the
right to join a union and similarly 90%
disapprove of any action by legislators
that would interfere with the right to
collectively bargain this bill
definitely interferes with the right to
collectively bargain because it makes it
harder for public sector unions to focus
on their job of
improving wages working conditions and
uh
benefits for our
members and uh the ability to serve our
communities whether it's you know
through our schools or through our town
Services um couple more things the red
tape this would cause and the difficulty
administering it is grossly understated
in in the very brief Bill someone would
have to keep track of where all these
employees are and it's hard enough for
us to find out who is in the covered
Workforce when we want to go and bargain
a contract getting that list out of the
public employer is very difficult
because there's a lot of change in our
Workforce we're talking day-to-day week
to week finding out who all the
employees are and who of them are by the
way permanent employees as opposed to
contracted employees in these days of
Workforce shortage when we can't fill
positions finding out who's actually an
employee and versus versus a temporary
is very difficult so you're creating
work for the local school district or
town um personnel office you're creating
work for is it the Department of Labor
or the public employees labor relation
board the bill was a little unclear on
that one thing in the taxt another thing
in the fiscal note um someone's going to
keep track of that someone's going to go
back and compare that to the list of
people who were eligible at the time the
union was certified some of our locals
have been around for 75 years and
there's no great
evidence
that employees in covered workplaces are
dissatisfied with the unions that are
there um there are already mechanisms if
they are they can work within the union
if they're a member and try and change
the way the union is run they can uh go
through the desertification process
that's already been talked about but
according to the Bureau of Labor
Statistics in work places that have
unions about
90% of workers choose to be members cuz
you can't force anyone to be a member we
had a whole big long hearing about that
last week we already know that so they
choose to join they choose to pay into a
union in New
Hampshire so um yeah we oppose this bill
it would tie us up in red tape it would
keep us from doing our job which is rep
representing our members bargaining for
better wages working conditions benefits
and resources to help us do our jobs
well for the people of the communities
of the Granite State um that's why we
oppose HB 735 we hope you'll find it an
expedient to legislate and if you have
questions I will try and take them but
um yeah they probably areer questions
yeah seeing none thank you ma'am
appreciate your your testimony
please and if you could introduce
yourself and who you where who you
represent thank you sure my name is uh
Doug
ingersol I'm the executive director of
the public employee Labor Relations
Board I've worked for the board since
2006 uh I'm not here to take a position
on the bill I'm here to give a hopefully
a very brief overview of processes that
are in the existing law so that you have
that context when you make a decision uh
or recommendation on this
bill um and also maybe to offer a
comment about the references to to the
Department of
Labor um starting with the number of
bargaining units there are about 678 in
the state 39 state two two Judiciary
three Community College three Plymouth
State five University system of New
Hampshire 69 City that are not school
district or law enforcement 40 county
332 education 75 law enforcement and by
that
uh I mean any any bargaining unit that
is strictly police officers or employees
of police
departments uh Municipal 104 which does
not include the school district or the
law enforcement but which which does
include
firefighters uh and then Keen State
College uh six so according to my math
that comes out to 678 bargaining units
the board uh has been in operation since
197 6 there were some bargaining units
that were grandfathered in at that time
but the vast majority have been
established through elections that we
have conducted since
1976 and elections for new bargaining
units are ongoing every year we probably
run elections for new bargaining units
at the rate of 5 to eight a year uh the
other kinds of Elections we run our
decertification elections which you've
heard about and challenge uh
elections uh so starting with a
decertification election employees have
the right under the
statute to file a petition supported by
what we call authorization cards signed
by 30% of the employees in the
bargaining unit saying they would like
us to conduct the decertification
election if necessary we have a hearing
to resolve any objections and and there
can be some legal objections and some
factual objections so it's not a simple
matter of filing paperwork and then
ordering an election um if an election's
in order we then start the election
process the employer is involved
throughout the union is involved
throughout um we have a pre-election
conference where we set a date and a
time for the election many elections are
done uh on the job site uh for uh
employers who have employees at multiple
work locations mail ballot elections are
another option
uh then we have a posting period of
usually two to three weeks so that
employees are informed and aware that an
election is is pending they'll see
information about the election that we
provide including the ballot uh there
are there are always at least two
choices on the ballot if it's a dessert
election uh the name of the incumbent
Union uh as well as no representative
and the no representative option is on
the ballot of every uh election that we
conduct and the outcome of the election
is determined by the majority of the
ballots cast not by the number of
employees in the bargaining unit so if
employees are interested in
participating they show up to vote uh
and then based on the number that vote
we see how the the uh ballots play out
and we declare the outcome um if there
is a majority vote for decertification
it means that for the next 12 months
there cannot be a ition filed to try to
reestablish that bargaining unit after
12 months uh a petition can be filed and
it would follow the same process that's
followed for the formation of new
bargaining units it would be simple
majority vote of the U number of the uh
the ballots
cast uh the other election that occurs
and I don't have exact numbers with me
today but decertification elections are
not a common occur
um so the other election process that we
hold is is known as a challenge election
and that's an opportunity um and a
mechanism that employees can use if they
want to move from one Union to another
Union um and it can be done in a couple
of ways it can be done with respect to
the existing bargaining unit and if we
approve it the election will have three
choices on the ballot the incumbent
Union the proposed new Union and no rep
representative uh the other way
challenge uh elections happen is if a
group of employees covered by an
existing bargaining unit want to form
their own independent bargaining unit
and we've seen that a couple times this
year with firefighters who have been in
with other Town employees uh but they
decide they want to be independent and
they want to be associated with uh for
example the iaff they will file
paperwork to remove their their
positions from the existing bargaining
unit we may have hearings if it's
approved they have a separate pending
request to run an election and then we
will run an election the incumbent Union
will still be on the ballot there the
proposed new Union and the no
representative choice will be on the
ballot uh the other thing that can
happen uh with bargaining units uh is a
surrender of a certification and that's
done by the union and we see that happen
when there is uh although we don't probe
uh when there's a lack of interest uh by
employees who are covered by the
bargaining unit and join the joining the
the union and paying dues if that
happens it doesn't make a lot of sense
for the union to continue to represent
and
if you know we probably get a handful of
these a year so there is a those those
bargaining units sort of Wither on the
vine uh so that's the high level
overview of the election uh process um
with respect to
the the current proposal um and the role
of the Department of Labor um I think
it's been recognized here that the
Public Employee Labor Relations Board
has exclusive jurisdiction over the
administration of 273a which is where
all bargaining units are the law that
covers all the formation of all
bargaining units and elections and the
Department of Labor is not involved at
all in that
process
um the idea that it may be necessary to
involve the Department of Labor to get
employee lists for different points in
time is not something that I had thought
about um it's if this uh bill becomes
law they could certainly serve as a
resource uh I'm not sure that they would
need legislatively to be uh in place
because I think there could be some
potential confusion in conflict between
the plrb and the Department of Labor and
my sense say a Department of Labor isn't
looking for more work um the other thing
I wanted to point out on employee lists
is we don't keep a record of what
employees show up to vote uh but we do
have a a record of our list of eligible
employees certainly going
comprehensively going back 20 years and
we have scanned in all of the old
certification files and decertification
files
which are mostly complete and a lot of
those files actually have employee lists
in them tick sheets that are at the
polling place that we use when we uh
conduct the election so that would be a
starting point uh but I anticipate the
major way to figure out if the are the
trigger has been uh has occurred here
would be Communications between uh the
plrb and the employer in question uh
asking them to research their records we
would look at our
records uh we would then make a
determination we would probably send out
a notice which would uh provide an
opportunity for
objections uh and then we'd go to
hearing if necessary to resolve those
objections and if the case got cleared
for election uh then we would go through
that
process um this bill does uh call for
the election outcome to be determined
differently than other elections that we
run which I think would has the
potential to create confusion um but
instead of just determining based on the
votes actually cast we would look at the
entire list of eligible uh voters so if
we had a unit with 100 eligible voters
but only 20 showed up to vote then
obviously uh that particular unit would
would not meet this recertification
requirement even if the 20 who showed up
or unanimous to continue
representation and then I I think on
rebound
elections um I think the wording is a
little unclear but I think the intent is
to have the same Arrangement that we
currently have with dessert that there's
a 12-month uh period when uh no attempt
to form the bargaining unit and have an
election uh can be uh held but after
that the any vote that's held would be
for a unit that was didn't meet the
recertification requirement uh they
would be subject to that majority of the
entire list as opposed to uh the process
we find we follow for a regular dessert
which would be the majority of the
employees who actually show up to
vote um so something to be said for
maybe having consistency between the
election procedures that we use now uh
and any procedures that are in this
statute um
um I'm not going to go into the the
details of how we conduct the elections
and how much time is involved I did my
best uh in our fiscal note to uh
determine a a financial impact I think
for us uh it would mean some additional
funding uh to reestablish a position to
have somebody sort of working
administratively almost full-time on
this to keep the ball rolling uh and and
then on the employer side um depending
on how complicated a particular case is
depending on how much the employers use
outside
Council uh they could encounter expenses
in my estimate that the option I had was
0 to 10,000 or 10,000 to 100,000 given
the rates that I think the private
attorneys charge who come to my office I
think it wouldn't take much before
there's a $10,000 legal bill in a
particular year especially if there are
multiple uh
recertification elections uh being
addressed so I'm sure I'm forgetting uh
some things I think you got a good
overview of the situation from the other
speakers today but what why don't I stop
there I'll answer any questions and you
can always email me and I'll Supply any
additional information if
necessary I appreciate good testimony uh
representa lry thank you Mr chair this
will be quick um could you get us the
information for resert desert and
surrender for like the last two years is
that possible to submit that to the
committee yep okay thank you great
question thank you representative
Schultz thank you Mr chair I have a dumb
question and I should know the answer to
this but who hires you who
chooses um who does this work I'll
answer that in a second but you asked
for resert desert and surrender So
currently there is no research procedure
right so there's new bargaining units
why don't I just do new bargaining units
any deserts and surrenders last two
clarification so I'm going to answer the
next question so the the answer is I'm
hired by the
board yep okay and represent
McKenzie thank you Mr Mr
chairman so you've been doing this for
for a
while my question to you
the process rolls along collective
bargaining rolls along we have an
obligation of the
law to provide uh once we're certified
to have the opportunity to
negotiate given
that what kind of impact would during
the middle of
negotiations all of a sudden this
triggers this this thing how how is the
the right to bargain collectively
balanced against against this particular
uh law which would be on the on at on
the best day disruptive as anything to
to the process yeah I mean clearly at a
minimum it would create uncertainty so
for example in the case of a school
district usually bargaining starts uh in
September uh in a perfect world
sometimes it doesn't really get rolling
until October November the objective for
all bargaining is to get a contract
negotiated in advance of the budget
submission date so all the necessary
paperwork can be completed so in the
case of a
municipality if there are new cost items
in a contract that gets in front of the
voters at the state level obviously
February 15th is the budget submission
date uh so there's already pressure and
there's been hearings in the past that
have talked about that
um we if an issue came up our if we had
a complaint about it and we also conduct
contested hearings on unfair Labor
practice complaints among other things I
anticipate our Direction and instruction
to the involved parties would
be uh you know until this bargaining the
status of this bargaining unit changes
you have to negotiate just like you've
always
negotiated um but on a day-to-day basis
whether that would be true I I I don't
know we are not out there in the field
at the bargaining table we only tend to
hear about things when things go wrong
or we get calls uh from unions and
employers asking for guidance uh because
maybe they're in tough negotiations and
our basic advice is look here's the
framework and you have to kind of work
your way through it and most of them
do followup for followup sir thank you
uh can you uh respond to uh what would
Happ happened uh under the failure to
represent if there was a a person a
member that came forward and said we I
was discriminated against or I wasn't
properly represented what is a
consequence the ultimate consequence for
that kind of behavior by a local union
so there is a unfair Labor practice
known as a a violation of Duty of fair
representation and we've had a few of
those over the last 10 years probably
less than five
uh and it's usually the result of an
employee who's unhappy with how the
union handled a grievance and the fact
that a union had decided not to advance
a grievance to binding arbitration which
is an expense both to the union and to
the employer uh and there's a legal
standard we use to evaluate uh those
cases uh I think in all of those cases
the the board's determination was that
the duty had not been viol ated but if
the duty is
violated uh we publish written decisions
all of the decisions and orders that the
board has issued back to 1976 are on our
website uh we also require certain
decisions to be posted in the workplace
to make sure uh the employees are aware
of the board's
determination um and depending on on how
egregious the conduct is we might keep
that case open so that we can monitor uh
the behavior of the the union to to make
sure that appropriate Corrections have
been
made repres representative AV Ling thank
you Mr chairman um we've heard a lot of
talk about um bargaining and everything
else um it only triggers between line
two and four can you explain to us what
so you're looking at the proposed Bill
correct yes yes sir page one
yes well if if the board
met then long story short we would start
the process to conduct an
election if if that's the question
asking but to to make that determination
there a lot of work would be necessary
to determine that the particular
bargaining unit is subject to the
recertification election process and we
don't currently have data in place that
would allow us easily to do that I
anticipate that we would have rulem so
that everybody would understand how that
process would
unfold and you know if we were to do
this I'm sure down the road it
would the unions may not like it and
public employers may not like it but we
would have a system in place that we
would consistently use which is what we
try to do in everything we want to be
consistent and predictable but we're not
there yet I'm I anticipate nine months
if this bill becomes law starting July
1st I anticipate probably nine months of
coming up with a system and going
through rul Mak
um to get something up and running I
don't think we can just start the
process with just this bill language in
place for
followup notwithstanding the department
of uh labor notation would Department of
Employment Securities be a more adequate
place to find employment information for
state not in my area but I assume that
one of those departments for various
reasons may have inventories of
employees at particular locations at
different points in time but I don't
know that for a fact thank you thank you
Mr chairman good
question representative
Sullivan would I be correct in thinking
that almost all public sector unions um
in New Hampshire would be sub subject to
this recertification at least you know
in in the short
term sooner or
later followup a
followup but wouldn't most of these U
public sector unions be old enough that
the vast majority of their employees
were not around during the original
certification I think I may have
estimated in the fiscal note that there
could be as many as 400 bargaining units
as of today that may be immediately
subject to the reer recertification
election requirement but I haven't uh
gone through our certifications and
looked at the
date probably a certification that's at
least 20 years old would fit into the
category you're talking about but there
have been a lot of new bargaining units
established over the last 20 years thank
you okay seeing no further questions
thank you sir for your testimony I
appreciate your
time and we've got about 34 minutes
before we turn into pumpkin so you could
manage your questions and testimony as
such I appreciate that
please Mr chairman member of this
committee my name is Scott Gober I
represent the teamsters here in New
Hampshire we to oppose this piece of
legislation I will be
quick it's anti-worker
right from the
rip no one in this room is fooled by it
I don't
believe
two I just went through an election in
my local
union so we have some accountability at
the local level already we are already
policing ourselves along with a lot of
outside agencies that look at us
regularly so theart of
accountability uh Falls to my membership
and my membership holds me accountable
as a recording Secretary of the
local I am also a working member for UPS
I've been there for 37 years I've
probably been to your home on multiple
occasions delivering multiple packages
to
you and those people that we represent
our ups members as well as well as
anheiser Bush as well as the department
of corrections as well as multiple
police agencies within the
state this piece of legisl
as outlined by the Department of Labor
and I really wanted to get up here and
speak to that but that was done by them
very well covered I believe has been
brought up many times that there isn't a
problem with the current resolution if
someone has a problem with their Union
in the state of New Hampshire there's a
process in place that process works and
that process has probably been used
within the past
month to two uh in our organization
already so it does work the members are
heard the people that you're concerned
about are heard as was already outlined
by the department and how to use that
process and I guess that's why I wanted
to come up and let you know that it is
working and it and it continues to work
and so we urge you to vote and expedient
to legislate thank you for your time
yeah thank you for your testimony I
appreciate you waiting around
any
questions thank you sir appreciate
it and John Kemp
yes good afternoon Mr chairman um by way
of introduction my name is John krupsky
I'm an attorney here in conquered I've
been practicing law since 1995 almost
exclusively for labor and employment and
have been practicing in front of the
plrb uh since
1995 I have the distinct honor and
privilege of testifying on behalf of the
New Hampshire Troopers Association and
the New Hampshire Troopers Association
Command Staff and we stand opposed uh to
House Bill
735 because it is in essence as said by
other people who have testified a
solution looking for a problem since
1976 almost 50 years
um the plrb has had a mechanism which
allows for certification desertification
and changing of certification and has
worked well over those 50
years if you wish to follow a petition
for certification any individual can do
that getting 30% of other people and why
do we do that think about it instead of
having elections just to have elections
to bring in bureaucracy expend money
expend time just to do it doesn't make
sense but if you have to have a majority
and you have 30% who say I'd at least
like to get a hearing then you get a
hearing and it makes sense it's not just
do it to do it but rather when there's a
showing of
Interest second part and and I think
that needs to be um brought up is that
individual union members as well as
collectively have a way to either
decertify or address if they think their
Union isn't doing something correctly
for example and I I'd like to um uh Leap
Frog over uh executive director angol um
I just want to let you know that if you
discriminate as a union if um you
violate the duty of fair representation
in an egregious manner you will be
desertified that desertification will go
away okay the other thing is that if an
individual on an individual basis does
not want to support a union
they have a right and it's actually been
in our law since
1976 that you cannot discriminate
against somebody for membership or
non-membership you're in the union and
in fact in
2018 the United States Supreme Court in
in the case of Janice said directly that
you can't even require contributions as
a fair share so individuals don't have
to contribute economically or be a
member as I said um this is a completely
unworkable bill um it's unworkable on a
lot of levels that I think has already
been addressed um and I'm happy to talk
offline to people on why it's further
unworkable but the one of the biggest
issues that two bit two last points I'd
like to make is one of the biggest
issues is it conflates the jurisdiction
of the do Department of Labor with the
Public Employee Labor Relations Board
the Public Employee Labor Relations
Board has exclusive
jurisdiction over certifications and D
certifications exclusive jurisdiction
the Department of Labor has no expertise
nor quite frankly knows what happens
over at the
plrb you've heard the director say they
don't have the data to do this why don't
they have the data because when you use
words like a majority of the people what
does that mean for example there are
sometimes elections where somebody will
be certified uh and I'll use the
Troopers as an example the troopers were
certified um I believe uh in the latter
' 70s early 60s and became an
independent Union in 1990 thereafter
they became another Union and broke off
and be became Command Staff and this so
which was the majority was it back in
1970 was it back in 1990 was it most
recently in the
2000s that's not addressed here okay the
other thing that um I'd like to address
and I think is important is we are
looking at and I've seen throughout uh
the state I represent locals throughout
uh New Hampshire I do negotiate and I
will tell you that this will stagnate
negotiations because if I don't know who
I'm going to be negotiating with I'm not
going to negotiate in Earnest because it
may be a new thing and you'll often see
that and I'll hear this from towns and
cities where they'll say hey can we hold
off on negotiations because we're having
a new board uh a new board being sworn
in here in the state they've said to us
in regards to State negotiations hey
let's wait to see um what governor aot
appoints to her written so it does
negatively impact and if that changes on
a regular basis then that will inhibit
the ability to reach Collective bargain
and and lastly which I think um needs to
be addressed um by this board and this
is uh right now and and uh executive
director Inus will hit on it and it's
extremely
important the way that the that 735
reads you have to have a majority of the
whole bargaining unit okay so if there's
200 people you you have to have 101
people vote to
recertify I'm asking you to look at your
experience look at the presidential
elections look at your elections were
you voted to represent your constituency
by 51% of everyone in your
District the answer is
no but that's what you're requiring
unions to do whether people want to vote
whether they want to exercise their
right not to exercise their franchise
and right now the way that it's worked
for 50 years over approximately 50 years
is that it's a majority of the people
who vote that's who makes the
decision if you change it to this manner
it makes it almost insurmountable
because I will tell you that public
employees um who serve this state work a
variety of different schedules they work
a variety of different times and quite
frankly some are disenchanted um with
participating in anything not just
unions how do you get that
51% you're setting this up for
failure that does not produce harmonious
Labor Management
relations the current law does and it's
been proven and it's happened over 50
years some of the discussions earlier
and I just want to make clear and I
think uh uh executive inou already said
it the Public Employee Labor Relations
Board only deals with public employees
in the state of New
Hampshire all the other things that
they're talking about that's through the
NL or something else because we don't
that the Public Employee Labor Relations
Board does not have jurisdiction over
private
employees um I will tell you too that
the other problem is thinking of uh and
and I'll end there I think I've made my
point if there's any questions or
clarifications I can provide I'd be
happy to do so Mr chairman or other
members of the board thank you for your
saying none please uh thank you thank
please always great to be between a
committee and uh going home so I'll try
to be quick uh for the record my name is
Greg Mo I'm the state director with u
Regal director with Americans for
Prosperity and here today testify in
support of House Bill 735 of will say
there was a similar Bill brought forward
in 2020 as an earlier speaker mentioned
I am glad that the sponsor didn't give
me one day's notice like in 20120 so I'm
happy about that piece uh but I will say
about uh in addition to what the the
representatives who brought the bill in
said I would just add that the one
distinction with uh public sector unions
is that they don't go away businesses go
away uh there's a great book called
built to last by Jerry porus and Jim
Collins and it talks about what makes
enduringly great companies and in it
they raised a point that less than one
half of 1% of businesses that are around
today were around 50 years ago so this
is a natural cycle going through in the
private sector that doesn't happen in
the public sector in the public sector
um I expect that the unions that were
here today will be most of them will
still be here 50 years from now and at
that point undoubtedly none of the
people in those bargaining units will
have ever had a a chance to choose
between which Union they might think
prefer they prefer as the one that uh
best represents
them I'll tell you that there's an
interesting experience I was I have a
friend who's wife is a is a public
school teacher uh they live in
Manchester she had been working in in
nashaa uh which is a aft
represented uh board um district and uh
she had a chance to come to work in
Manchester which given to commute from
driving down from Manchester to as every
day I would make that choice too uh and
she and she found out that were an Nea
affiliate and uh she expressed to me
that that she liked what she was getting
in Nashville better than what she's
getting in Manchester and she said do we
vote on that and I said there was a vote
but it was before you were born uh so
that's one of the things that I would
just encourage people to consider and
that part doesn't change in in public
sector because because governments stay
around they don't go out of business uh
as for the actual language in the bill
there are a number of states that do
public sector uh recertification none of
them do do them this way um none of them
none of them do this way I'm not sure
that this is uh necessarily the best way
to do it not just because of the
additional burden it would add to the
employers to track all the information
as to when someone's start date was and
when the certification was or most
recent certification was uh but also uh
but also be because it creates a level
of uncertainty and almost as
representative selvan pointed out almost
all the union or good a good chunk of
the Unions would immediately implicated
and it would probably overwhelm the
plrb uh so I would say that that as
you're considering this legislation you
need to consider an orderly fashion in
which if you're going to go through this
route an orderly fashion so you break
the work up so you're not suddenly
deluging the plrb with with um hundreds
potentially uh of of recertification
elections uh just goes with some with
some what other states do the State of
Florida it's it's 10 years so once every
10 years they have recertification the
state of Missouri is every 3 years the
state of Iowa has recertification
whenever there's a new contract uh
probably the easiest and simplest one of
all those is the state of Wisconsin
which goes through the annual election
process so when you're going through
your annual benefits and you're deciding
what benefits you what payroll
deductions in other words you're picking
your health plan and picking your other
benefits it adds paying union dues and
uh if the number of employees who opt to
pay to pay Union who dropped below 50%
then that automatically triggers a
recertification election so this is I'm
just just talking about what some other
states do in terms of the me the
triggering mechanism uh to begin the
recertification so just wanted I know
the the the prime sponsor mentioned that
he's not hung up on this particular
method so I just wanted to offer the
committee a few other ideas as to what
some other states do so happy to take
any
questions representative
thank you Mr chairman thank you Mr Moore
um so does the in dist just St Wisconsin
does the Department of Labor
track would you know if the Department
of Labor tracks the uh union membership
or if it's another department so the uh
as I recall state of Wisconsin doing a
little bit of of research uh in advance
of this bill what they do is they have
basically their annual Open Season so
like a lot of businesses you have an
open season and and the IND individual
employees will come through and they'll
fill what their payroll deductions are
other which which category Health Plan
do they take so how much takes that
takes out of it of a deduction out their
pay check and one of the one of the the
fields they fill out is uh paying union
dues and the way that works is so when
the employer sees that that fewer than
half of the bargaining unit have
selected union dues that triggers
notification to their U Public Employee
Labor Relations
Board follow please so it would be
basically an intern inter issue that the
union would have to un the union would
or the employer would have to report
right the employer thank you thank you
Mr okay Mr Moore thank you so much oh
I'm sorry John L representative L uh
sorry and thank you Mr Moore um I asked
president Brackett earlier if he had
anybody that was um looking for this
legislation for something like this if
you have people at are where are they
how come we don't have more people here
I would love to hear testimony from
folks uh representative I
I I don't know how many people are able
to to take off work at 3:30 on on a
Tuesday afternoon it we find this as a
challenge where if we wanted to get
people together at 7:30 somewhere we can
get lots of our activists together try
to get people together during the work
day it's it's a challenge for a followup
thank you um well to your point the
right to work people we had people here
all day that were opposed to the bill
and they came and spoke is that a
statement or a question so why would
that be any
different I'm I'm I'm not sure I follow
but but look if people people obviously
can take their time in the manner that
they see
fit thank you Mr thank you m uh
representative McKenzie thank you thank
Mr
chairman so you've heard about all the
mechanisms currently in the law the
allow employees to make decisions to
decertify their Union to challenge the
leadership to uh you know to be be uh
reprimanded uh for their inability to
properly represent their their people so
we have all of this structure within the
current law that is working we've heard
from the from the chair of the of the
committee of the uh
plrb so tell me what more do we need to
do in New Hampshire
without disrupting everything what more
would you think we need to do when when
all of these things are in place and all
this mechanism in place for us to do all
the things that you're talking about let
employees make the choices why do we
need this legislation right now as I as
I said uh excuse me I'm lose my voice uh
as I said there are going to be a number
of bargaining units across New Hampshire
where literally no member of that of
that bargaining unit had a chance to
choose which Union would be representing
them now that's not
sure well they wouldn't have a chance to
certify and ultimately they don't know
if the grass is any Greener because they
don't have they don't have the choice to
determine that Mr chairman just one one
correction here okay so is there a
question to be formed a quick and
efficient question is you said that the
uh the employees wouldn't have the right
to decertify the union that's not what I
said what did you say I said that there
are a number of bargaining units across
the state of New Hampshire where none of
the employees there voted to
certify okay thank you Mr Moore thank
you so much I'd like to call uh Mr car
Labor good afternoon chair as members of
the committee uh my name is John garrian
I am general counsel with the State
Department of Labor um given the time
I'll simply note uh the Department of
Labor as been said has no existing role
when it comes to public uh employee
collective bargaining agreements we have
no jurisdiction uh over that world and
for uh discussions on the fiscal impact
I'll just refer to our fiscal note I'm
happy to take
questions are there any
questions thank you for that
clarification representative avalani
Mackenzie well uh representative
McKenzie yes on you so G given the the
charge that you have under the
law um do you have either the capacity
or the legal uh framework to be able to
take on the responsibility of managing
what this uh legislation is
saying uh the bill would require new
Personnel new work
processes um it would uh require new
jurisdiction for us in order to obtain
these records store these records um
review these records um and take
enforcement action if necessary if
records weren't forthcoming um and to
then um process them internally
so okay good representative avalani that
was half my question representative
McKenzie um the follow-up to that is uh
would Employment Services be a better
resource that already has those process
half or more those processes in place
that you would have to R for uh I I I I
can't speak to their capacity or
processes I do know they do track
employee numbers as part of of their
role and employee wages as part of their
role um regulating their systems I don't
know to what granular degree they do
that um I would have to refer them or
refer you to uh Deputy Commissioner lers
chair all right thank you sir thank you
uh ladies and gentlemen represent uh
Representatives uh really appreciate
your time on this bill and I appreciate
all the testimony and I close the
you uh committee members um great job
today thank you for your patience your
attentiveness your good questions and uh
and hard work on this
testimony uh we will meet meet next week
at 4: on the 4th at
10: uh we've got six Bills currently
scheduled uh representative Solomon and
I will go through those again uh with
378 in mind uh before we leave today and
so that'll come out on the next calendar
we will exec uh those bills that we
heard today will exec next week and uh
um so we'll do that probably for the
first hour and a half 10 to 10 10 to
11:30 and then we'll hear bills after
that are any questions comments yes
representative Schultz ma'am always a
question thank you Mr chair just real
quick I assume the minimum wage and
subminimum wage bills will be on that
day thank you that's correct any other
questions great good job today we will